Hello!
Hello, everyone!
Hi!
Hi, guys!
We are back with more in Missionary Zero.
We're here to save the moon!
Yeah!
So, like, if you guys can tell, we're all white except for mint.
Uh... Oh.
I didn't get the memo.
At least this time we all have our spacesuits on.
We all...
Yeah!
We all have our own little spacesuits this time!
We're letting us rent them out.
Thanks to the artist that I found.
Oh!
That you found?
Yeah, Min's the main character now.
It's me!
Um, the reason why we were a little late is because I actually made a public lobby.
...and...
Ray, are you watching?
Are you watching this?
I'm sorry if we didn't give you a warm welcome.
Yeah!
We were like, get out!
Leave!
Who are you?
I feel bad if they, like, aren't our viewer and then they joined and we were all just like, who is that?
Yeah!
We were all just yelling at him!
We were all just screaming at him!
Did he hear you guys?
He never said hi!
Yeah.
Yeah, he never said hi to us too.
We were all like...
Are you to be fair?
It was like, four women screaming at him.
I feel like he was intimidated.
I know, just be like, what?
What is it?
Where are you?
He's like, get out of here!
And I'm like, wait, I can kick him, guys.
But, um, it was actually really funny because, like, when we were all getting together for the stream.
Um, Min and Nimi were like, I don't remember how I played a game.
No.
But then the thing is, on the other side, the yellow women, Doobie and I, we were making a plan.
Yeah.
They were making a plan!
Yeah, we were making a plan.
We could be carried today.
We wrote notes down.
Yeah, we wrote notes.
We are reliable people, right, Doobie?
Uh-huh.
Yeah, us yellow women, we know what to do.
We worked it out in our brains.
Yeah, we worked it out.
What are you guys bringing to the table, huh?
Yeah, what were you guys doing?
I break the color, I break the, I do the cooking, I do the cleaning.
What about you, Nimi, huh?
What's your job?
I'm, I'm white.
I'm
prepared, I forgot my homework at home.
What were we doing?
I don't remember.
Okay, okay, so, so, remember this area where there was that man that kept killing us?
So, we're gonna skip that for now.
We're gonna do the easier task.
Okay, okay.
So, um, the thing is, um, the, the, the trees with orange leaves, that one, um, we dug up two of those.
But what happened to those items?
Oh, no.
Oh, yeah, we don't have any items.
I guess we gotta get them again.
I feel like, yeah, so, okay, but we have to, because we've, I already see one tree, yellow, orange tree in front of me.
And there's one.
But it says two out of five in the.
Yeah, but we, we need to put the items in the yellow car.
Oh.
So, we need to figure out.
We lost that.
Maybe, maybe it's in that, maybe it's in the, the, the vending machine, remember?
Yeah.
Oh, it could be.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go to the vending machine first.
How do we...
Okay, hold on, I need to...
What's the controls again for this game?
The ship is right.
Wow, thank you.
There's a vending machine over here.
Oh.
Alright.
This building.
Yeah, this is the building.
Oh, there's a shop.
Oh, I found it.
There, there, there.
There is.
Okay.
Oh, they're right here.
So, the thing about it is that, it's just one yellow car.
I don't remember where the, I don't know where the yellow car is, but I know where all the trees are.
Well, I don't know where all the trees are, but I know where some of the trees are.
We gotta explore for the trees.
Yeah.
So...
So, someone has to carry the other two items.
Okay, everyone.
Alright, let's go.
I'll watch.
Who is breathing?
Okay, so...
We got this tree.
Look at those cats.
Yeah, I think it's the cats.
Oh, there, there's also a tree over here on this side.
Wait, did we dig the...
We didn't dig that one, right?
Uh, I'm not sure, but there's like a...
Right.
Oh!
Watch out!
Don't die.
Oh, yeah.
Alright.
Dig.
I'll carry this one.
Alright.
Yay!
Okay, we still, we need to find the yellow car for this too.
Oh, I found another one!
Oh my god, the cat's here.
Oh, wait, that thing's bad.
That's a cat?
Yeah, the cat's here!
Oh!
Meow, meow, meow!
It's okay, it's okay.
I'll run past it.
Okay.
It's fine, I live.
I think it's on to me.
Okay, it's fine, it's fine.
Most of us is...
Oh, no!
Nope, he's behind us.
I think we lost mint, and I think I'm bringing it this way.
Oh, I have to see the yellow car anywhere.
Okay.
Can we dig this one already?
I think it would show like a pile of dirt.
Wait, is that yellow car?
Wait, that's yellow!
Is that yellow?
Is it yellow?
No, that's blue.
It's blue.
It's not yellow.
Where did the mint go?
I see her.
She's not white.
Oh, wait, no, that's...
Oh.
Hi!
Wait, that's...
Oh!
Oh my god!
Get over here!
Ah!
Oh my god.
Also, I hope this sounds okay.
We just started the game.
I can't believe she was alive.
I thought she was dead.
Our savior, our hero.
Our hero!
See, that's why you were the main character.
I thought you were... We all thought you were dead.
No, I was just by myself.
I was scared.
We were literally trying to revive you.
I think we gotta find the yellow car and then maybe the...
There's a thing all the way over there.
Be careful.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Oh, what the hell is that?
Hey, he's here.
This guy's here.
Oh, wait.
The yellow car's over here.
Oh.
Okay, okay.
Wait, what's he saying?
No, never mind.
I thought it was yellow.
I'm blind.
Oh, it's not.
Yellow woman can't see yellow.
Never mind.
Wait, yellow woman can't see yellow?
Yeah.
It looked yellowish.
We just needed a...
The orange, finally.
Yeah, we should help him.
Oh.
Pick the orange.
Do we have it?
I don't remember where it was.
I don't remember, too.
Oh, we just didn't find this goddamn yellow car.
It has to be, like, outside here.
In the parking lot.
It's inside in the... in here?
Oh.
In the middle?
Maybe?
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
That's part where we left.
There was a guy over here, so we should be careful.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I remember.
I...
I definitely remember.
Maybe that's on this side.
I'm gonna check this side.
Oh, my...
Like, cause we didn't go too...
We didn't explore this area too much.
Did we explore this...
Did we explore all of this side?
I don't think so.
This is, like, the part that loops around, isn't it?
Yeah.
It's probably down here, right?
Oh.
Yeah, this was the car and...
There's so many cars.
Surely one of them is yellow?
Yellow car!
To get in.
yellow car.
Oh.
No.
Please.
What if we have to go all the way back to the beginning?
Oh, there's no way.
There's no way.
Nooo.
I thought you took notes?
I did!
I took notes!
But there's so many cars.
Then the guy, there's the jumpy guy.
There's the jumpy guy.
Oh, there's the jumpy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna go forward.
I'm going forward.
I'm going for it, I'm going for it.
Okay, here we go.
We went left, right?
Okay, let's go right.
There has to be one yellow car.
Maybe it's with all these guys in here.
Yeah, it could be over here.
Oh, that's true, that's true.
Aren't we missing someone?
I don't know, there's no cars over here.
Oh my god, are we?
Mimi?
Wait, where's your other green woman?
She's fine, right?
Green woman lost.
I thought I just saw her over here.
Maybe she split up.
Split up, gang.
All right, well, wait, where's Doobie?
Where's the other yellow woman?
Oh, okay, let's see it.
There, let's see.
Oh, hello, oh, nice.
Wait, where did you drop your... I dropped the battery somewhere, because I died.
Oh, oh.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
We'll find there.
Oh, I see it, I see it, I see it.
I got it.
Doki's got it, yeah.
I got it, I got it.
So we gotta go... we gotta go... uh... wait, where my shovel?
You can have multiple items in your inventory.
Wait, what happened to my shovel?
It's back there.
Okay, I got my... wait.
Wait, I can't... oh, no, I can't carry the shovel, because it's too heavy.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, where did Doobie go?
Doobie?
Should we... should we... She should be fine, right?
Right?
I'm not sure she's just looking for the yellow car.
Yeah, the goddamn elusive yellow car.
Yeah.
I don't think it's out here.
Is it not?
I mean, right to the right is the other guy, yeah.
Oh my god, okay.
I thought it was, like, closer.
It's... oh!
Wait, Doobie did something.
What?
What did Doobie do?
Wait, how do you know Doobie did something?
Sherry him, I'm gonna check if it's yellow!
Ah, he's following you!
Okay, I'm gonna check if it's yellow, guys.
Guys, it's yellow!
It's yellow, it's yellow, it's yellow, it's yellow!
That's the yellow car.
Please head over there, put the battery in!
They're all... Just put it in!
Okay, we found it.
Okay, one out of five.
Wait, where's Nimi?
I'm a hero.
Okay, but now we're missing Nimi.
Wait, are you alive?
Oh my god, I have so many!
Nimi, you're so...
It's okay, we're fine.
We're so safe.
See, we're okay.
I think we lost Nimi.
Wait, wait, Nimi, you're alive!
Wait, Nimi!
We found the yellow car!
Hello.
We found the yellow car.
Oh wait, Nimi!
I couldn't tell because you were all white!
We dropped the battery near the yellow car, though.
Oh, okay, okay, so we found the yellow...
It's on the back of the car.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, I'll take... I'll take Doobie to it.
Okay.
I'll lure them out, don't worry.
I found a map of all the batteries and where the car is.
It's over there, though.
We can go afterwards.
Okay, yeah, nice, nice.
So, we just need to find...
We just have like two more batteries and then...
Because that unlocks one of the electrical boards.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
See, I told you.
I told you I took notes.
Run through the building.
It's okay, I live.
Where is that random battery?
The house told it existed.
Where is it?
Where is this battery?
Oh!
Where is...
Where is the other battery?
Oh, there it is.
Okay, okay.
That's cool!
Wait, where am I now?
I don't know.
Wait, where is...
We say certain items are buried in...
Okay, I'll follow Doobie, Doobie...
Oh, Dad, that's the tree!
There's a tree!
Oh my god.
You're so...
You're still chasing after her.
Oh, I see!
Wait, I see the tree.
I see it, I see it.
I got it here.
Oh!
Which white woman is this?
Which one is this?
Which green woman?
Who are you?
Come here, come here, come here.
Come here.
It's here, it's here, it's here, it's here.
I dug it.
Oh, you got it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got one of them.
Alright, here's a building that'll show the last map of the last battery.
Okay, and then you can pick that up.
Man!
I'm here!
Oh, there's one in the back, too.
Wait, there's a body!
Oh, they're safe!
Oh, save, save, save, save!
What is that?
It's a giant headman.
I'm so jumpy today, holy cow!
There's a map here.
Okay, so we need one more.
We're missing one more battery.
I don't know which one we got.
Yeah, it's kind of hard to tell.
I think we just need the one right here that you passed, no?
No, no, we need one more.
I think two more.
No, yeah, so it has to be on the other side.
Where all the other trees were.
Wait, did we save?
Yeah, we did.
Yeah, okay.
Wait, what happened to the... Did you guys pick up the other battery?
No.
Which...
It's okay.
The one that I just dug up, it's like over there, but also there's a...
Oh yeah, that's what I was saying.
I think...
Is that not the last one?
No, no.
It's three out of five, so we're missing one more.
Uh...
Oh, oh.
You're right.
I think...
You know, there's numbers.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
I can't count!
Okay, we have to go to the yellow car.
Alright, I'm gonna see if I can find the last...
Wait, I see a tree over...
No, maybe it's just a tree like...
Maybe.
I'll go over.
I'll check it.
Doesn't hurt.
Wait, how do we get out?
Oh, here we go.
There's a door.
Wow, thanks, Doki Bird.
No problem.
The wisdom is...
Is infinite.
Oh, Doki Bird.
I'm almost positive we've gotten this.
Yeah, we...
Yeah, but some of the...
It says, like, some of them.
Did we dug it out?
Wait, I'll give you guys the battery and I'll go back to the map and check...
Okay.
There might be one over here.
Watch out for the hell!
It's okay, you can't reach me.
It's too thick.
Oh, you're right.
You stuck trapped.
Okay, this is a dead end.
I thought I could get to the other side.
Wait, I can!
Yeah.
Is there any trees here?
Trees.
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember.
Oh, so it's like a shortcut.
Oh, yeah, you have to go back to the yellow car.
Can you...
Do you think you can do it?
There's a guy right inside, no?
I just want some walk.
Oh, it's um...
It's the orange things.
Little orange glows.
Oh, yeah.
Maybe it's back here.
Okay.
Oh yeah!
Oh my god, where is the last tree?
Hello, TV man.
Oh, wait.
This is for me?
That's really kind of you.
With your help, I think I might finally manage the head replacement.
I've heard there's a deeper path in the basement that leads straight into the laboratory.
See you in the basement, and check your map.
There's a hidden way into the basement outside of the main building.
Oh?
Oh, what?
Oh, okay.
Oh, he's gone.
I didn't really process what he meant by that.
There's a secret way to the basement.
Outside the main building.
Wait, no, not this way.
Sorry, I'm lost.
Yeah, where are we going?
We need... We're literally missing one tree.
One tree.
One dream.
We must have gone this long.
It's just... It was dug.
Yeah, see, like, this is dugged up.
So we got this one.
Was there another one?
There was another one on the other side.
We got that one.
Yeah, that's three.
So we're... We need... Here, hold on.
Let's save right here, just in case.
Oh, Doobie should be alive, right?
Right?
No, yeah, Doobie is alive.
So maybe to the right?
Okay, we got... That's three.
Watch out!
Oh, watch out!
He's coming!
Oh, no!
Three, four... Where the fuck is the... That's the fifth tree!
That's the fifth tree!
This one?
We had to have gotten this one.
Apparently we got this one.
But I counted five!
What happened to the last battery?
I counted.
I think it's missing somewhere.
Maybe we dropped it when somebody died, and we don't realize.
Oh, no!
Did we respawn in somewhere?
That's... That's not a good thing.
Uh, what... Was it inside this building when we spawned?
That's not good.
We're... We're literally missing...
There's a picture of the map with my phone.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, nice!
The thing is, Doobie, we found all the trees, but...
Those trees have been dugged up.
But we counted one tree twice.
Did we count one tree twice?
Okay.
The far right.
One...
Two...
I think it's, like, all the way to the right.
All the way to the right?
All the way down this way.
Okay, I'll... I'll give you the shovel.
Wait, actually, wait.
Green women!
Put the battery in.
One of you guys should lure.
Yellow women will find the last tree.
Let's split up, gang.
All right, let's go.
Let's go here, right?
Okay.
Is this... Is this a good idea?
It'll be fine.
I'm trusting those two.
I don't know if it's well placed...
They got it.
Okay, one.
There should be one, like, all the way over here.
I think.
Oh, wait.
I bet it's on the other side.
No, that's the...
Like, of this lot.
Didn't we... No, we...
We got it.
It's the one next to the house, remember?
We dug that up together.
Yeah, but...
There's...
That one over there, but what if we keep going?
I don't see an orange tree, though.
Wait, what is that thing over there?
I think that's...
Maybe we'll unlock that later?
Oh...
Well, I want to open this gate.
Maybe, uh...
It has to be on the other side.
Because I was looking at the map, and there's a bunch of trees here that are super close to each other.
Oh, I think they already put it in.
Oh, they did it!
Yes, four out of five.
You guys did it!
The green women did it!
We did it!
We're still trying to find the orange tree.
We're still trying to find...
You counted how many?
I don't know.
YouTubers aren't very good at counting.
You...
YouTubers are not good at counting.
Oh, an egg.
Oh!
Oh, egg.
Because we dug that tree over there.
We dug the tree.
Alright, we gotta go fast.
We gotta go fast.
Wait.
Yeah, we're gonna make it.
I believe.
I feel like it might be in here.
Oh!
Wait, what's this?
Yeah.
I found it!
Oh, he's right behind me, isn't he?
Oh!
He's right behind me, isn't he, guys?
Hello?
Oh, my God!
His head extends!
Oh, I don't like that.
No, I don't think so.
Wait.
Okay, so, we got...
Where is...
Where is this?
This map is so confusing.
Alright.
Blue the car?
Yeah, what is the blue?
That's where we are.
So, we got the one...
We got the tree to the left side.
So, we need to get...
These three.
This is a confusing map.
I know!
I'm like...
Snowsets!
Doobie even took a photo of it.
The real...
This is the real horror.
Reading a map.
Who is that out there?
That's Doobie.
Oh, Doobie!
Doobie?
Blair witching out here.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I don't know, I'm fixing something.
You guys are fixing something on us.
You're good, you're good.
Okay, don't worry.
We'll protect you, Doobie.
We'll protect you.
Ah!
Did you guys find it?
No.
We got this.
Like, it's on the other side.
That's the thing.
The tree.
Alright.
We had it.
Maybe someone dropped it.
No, it said we didn't dig it though.
At chat.
Where is it?
Where the fuck is the last tree?
It's over there.
Over where?
Okay.
Just follow the road.
But I've dug that.
We've dug this tree.
One.
Okay.
Tree.
Is there a tree in here?
There.
Wait.
At the car?
Okay.
We dug this one.
There's no pile here.
One.
Okay.
Tree one.
And then two is the one on the cross.
Two.
Tree.
Three.
It's here.
Which we've also dug.
Three.
And then... four is on the far right.
Dug four out of five.
It says it on the passwords.
Yeah, okay, and then four is over here.
This one's dug up too.
Four.
We didn't dig here.
We did not dig here!
No, I think it reset because we definitely did before.
It was right here.
Mint, pick this up.
Why me?
It's your fault.
It's me!
It's my fault?
Okay.
It's always the main character's fault.
Okay, I'm the main character.
I'll put this in.
Do we have to like start the car or something?
No, it opens an electrical board.
I'm gonna watch from here.
Yeah?
Yeah, I don't wanna... I don't really wanna deal with that.
I don't... I don't really wanna be a part of that.
Hey, it's always safer over here.
Yeah, I feel so safe.
Okay, after that, we just need to put that in electrical board.
We have to go to the laboratory lab for that.
Oh, we have to go back to the lab?
Yeah, yeah.
You should have got it, right?
I don't even remember where it is.
Oh, me too.
I thought one of us did.
I thought one of us took the notes for that.
I just took notes on where we were dying.
Uh...
Wait, I don't see the objective anymore on the top.
Yeah, so they got it, but they still have to bring the electrical board over.
Oh, okay.
Some of my chat was like, Team Yellow hiding.
Um, we're not hiding.
We're just, um...
We're thinking.
Yeah, we're thinking here.
Yeah.
We're strategizing for the green women.
Exactly.
Mm-hmm.
We're the guides.
We're the players.
Yeah, we're the Sherpas.
We're the man in the chairs.
Exactly.
We're here to delegate not to do.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, yeah.
It's definitely not like Phasmophobia where the scared...
the most scared person sits in the van.
Yeah, yeah.
No, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, you can tell that I'm not one of them because...
I have a shovel.
And you have the lab.
Yeah.
Yeah, so they need us.
It is taking them a while though.
I hear them coming back.
Hello?
Green women?
Are they...
We could probably make it to the next building.
There's the saves over there.
Oh.
Oh wait.
Oh wait, I think I see them.
That's one of them.
What happened to the other one?
What was in the trunk?
Did you get it?
That was your job.
Oh, no.
There was a guy right there!
My dog was to put in the thing.
Wait.
What happened to Nimi?
Uh-oh.
Um...
Sheba?
Did we go to the save point?
That's why there were two of you.
One to grab the item and the other to put it in.
No, there was a guy right behind me.
It was blocking the...
The...
The trunk.
We have to go this way.
Oh, yeah!
Okay.
That trunk.
All that junk junk in that trunk.
Okay, we got...
Oh wait, there's a save point here, right?
Yeah.
Oh, is there?
Alright, Nimi.
What did mint do to you?
Get you drunk.
Get you loved drunk.
Go!
Wait, you guys have to grab the...
The electrical board.
Yeah, where's the electrical box?
I don't know!
It's in the back of the trunk!
We gotta go get out!
Oh!
Oh my God!
I'll be a hero!
I see it!
Go!
They can't stop all of us!
No, I think they can.
They could.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm okay.
Oh my God!
That scared the shit out of me.
Did you get it?
We got it.
Yay!
Yeah, we gotta take it down to the lab.
Wait, no.
This goes to the roof.
Oh my God.
He's here?
Wait, that's the rock.
How did we get to the lab?
I thought it was this way.
It was the other one.
It was the...
Other one?
Remember when we had to go to like...
The staircase?
Yellow women?
What...
What was the plan here?
Um...
Look, the yellow women had a little like...
There's a little snafu with the yellow women.
Okay?
We had a lot of plans.
We just brought up the wrong plan.
Yeah.
Plan A.
Yeah, yeah.
This is plan B.
Now we're going to do plan C.
Oh...
Or plan D.
I should...
Okay.
I'm okay.
You just lost somebody?
Wait, who did we lose?
Oh!
It's okay.
This is all part of plan C.
Plan D for Doki.
Yeah.
There you go.
Let's see.
Plan C.
Hey, all according to plan.
Wait, not this way, not this way.
That's not the plan part.
It's just... Slenderman's in there.
Yeah, but this is where we went to the lab, remember?
It was like through these stairs.
Are you wondering if you can't believe it?
I think so, I think so.
Yeah, it was this one, right?
Okay.
Or was it the other side?
Oh, no, here.
We had to go up.
I don't remember what the object was.
I don't remember.
Wait, I remember.
We had to go...
We had to go to the basement, remember?
And then take another elevator.
Guys, maybe we shouldn't have waited two weeks to do a part two.
It's a weird...
Wait, I remember.
Wait, it's all coming back to me.
It's right here.
Oh my... Oh my guy!
Where did he come from?
Isn't there a way over here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's all sinking.
I... Okay.
Is there a save point in here?
It was like in the elevator, remember?
Where was the elevator?
It was like down here?
Oh yeah, it was down here.
With the plan.
Exactly, I have a plan.
There's a save, there's a save.
It's so dark in here.
There you go.
See?
Hi!
Alright, and then we take this elevator.
I'm trying to press the elevator button.
My item is blocking.
Okay.
And then...
We go to basement two.
And then we go to another elevator.
And then we go down.
I...
You're saying a lot of shit right now.
It makes sense to me.
I get it.
Yeah, yeah, you just gotta...
Okay, the thing is...
I...
I don't remember which...
It was this way, right?
We...
We don't know where you're trying to...
I didn't think it was this way.
There's a guy, there's a guy, there's a guy!
Oh my God!
Okay.
Wait.
Wait, I'm...
Give me a sec.
Wasn't it the main elevator and then you select like a different floor?
No, no, no.
Cause we had to take two elevators.
So like, it was from here...
That we went to a different...
Oh, I remember!
Cause we...
We went to the...
You said, I remember like five times.
Remember when we had to run past the other guy?
To get to the...
This would have happened if Rafe was here.
Oh, see, Doobie remembers!
My fellow yellow woman remembers.
We have to run past this guy.
There's a guy over here, by the way.
I don't think we run that way, but...
Was it this way?
No, it was this way.
Guys, guys, see, I remembered.
I...
And then we go this way.
Let's see, look!
Remember this guy!
We saw him!
Yeah, yeah.
See?
I knew I remember...
And then basement too!
I think they're dead.
So I...
I think so.
I don't think they're alive.
I think we...
We'll have to leave them.
It's okay.
It's for the...
We're heroes.
Aren't we supposed to have, like, survivor's guilt or something?
It's okay, not when you're a hero.
Okay, no, no guilt at all.
No guilt.
Because we're doing it for the greater good.
Their sacrifice...
Their sacrifice will be remembered.
And then...
Boom!
We did it!
See?
No, no, no.
No, that's just...
That's just guilt.
You gotta stop feeling guilty, Nimi.
Okay, I'll forget about them.
I'll have to go.
Alright.
As...
As the moment you forgot about...
Forget about them...
You'll feel so much better.
The weight will lift on your shoulders.
It wasn't your fault, Nimi.
It was their fault.
Yeah, because they weren't heroes.
Yeah, because they didn't follow...
Follow us, you know?
Yeah, they should have followed us.
We knew what we were doing.
Yeah.
So it was their fault.
Alright, we opened the hatch.
See?
Plan C worked, Nimi.
Okay.
It seems like the moon is not floating away.
Yeah, because...
We have to open the second hatch.
So there's two hatches.
Okay, basement two.
You think the moon was made out of helium, you know?
I'm telling you, it's gonna float up there like a party city balloon.
Oh, wait!
You're alive!
What happened to...
Oh, oh, okay.
Okay.
See, you followed the wrong yellow woman.
I told you I had a plan.
There's no loyalty here?
No, okay.
The yellow car plan was my plan.
She's in charge of the other plan.
So...
What was the other plan?
The other plan was the...
You didn't even know where the yellow car was.
I found the yellow car!
What do you mean?
I was a hero!
For the record, I've had survivor's guilt this whole time.
No, she did.
She forgot about you.
She freaking...
For the record, I could always hear your voice.
Yeah, I was talking.
I could hear you guys, too.
Okay, we gotta...
We gotta go revive the other yellow woman because she actually has the...
She has the...
The part two of this plan.
Oh, okay.
I was only...
Wait, what did you guys do down there?
Oh, we opened the hatch for the moon.
Yeah, yeah.
We just need to open the second hatch, but...
The second yellow woman has part two.
I was only part one.
Okay.
Alright.
So how did she die?
So we could avoid that.
The guy got her.
And where is this...
And where is this guy you speak of?
Mr. Slenderman!
We could just jump, right?
Oh, no.
No, I don't...
No, we have to go through the guy.
So...
Ladies first.
I think if you just run for it...
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Oh, he'll only get one of us.
He'll only get one of us.
Wrong elevator!
He can't even come in here.
Nice, I was waiting for you guys.
With the door closed?
Yeah, for safety.
When would you see someone coming down the hall, and you're in the hallway with the door closed, but...
I'm just...
I'm just trying to save energy.
Same!
Doobie, it's your turn for part two.
Part two of the plan.
All right.
All right, but you guys have fun of me.
I'm not doing the plan.
No, no, I was just saying...
I heard you.
No, I was saying that...
I was part...
Okay, maybe that was karma.
You can't come in here!
No, please no.
Okay, so...
Who was it?
Who was the...
Who said...
That was my revenge.
That might have been deserved.
He was like, you can't come over here.
How do we get back to like the annex anyways?
It's the...
Up there.
We have to go out.
Yeah, we have to go outside.
Watch out for him.
He's a sneaky one, that guy.
We'll just...
Yeah, that was very...
He's there.
We can walk around him!
I knew it.
I'm a hero.
I just had to walk around.
We just had...
I just had to wait for them to die.
Alright.
I just had to wait.
I just had to wait until...
Don't worry.
Wait.
Someone else is...
Someone else is on the other side?
Wait.
Um...
Excuse me.
I'm closer to the objective.
So the other person has to die.
Not me.
I'm literally closest to the objective.
What do you mean?
I'm literally here, where we're supposed to be.
Okay, no, they have to die, not me.
It's 2v1.
I don't know that.
It could be 1v1, for all I know.
I'm literally next to the objective, so if anything, they should come to me.
Wait, I hear them!
Hello?
Are they lost?
Oh my god, are they lost?
Did anything not figure out where to go?
Hello?
Marco?
No, I'm literally on part 2 of Plan C.
This is part 2 of Plan C.
They just have to head here.
Wait, how are they at the very beginning?
Marco?
Hello?
Oh my god, there they are!
Okay, don't worry.
I know where to go.
I was waiting for you guys.
Okay.
We need Doobie, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a safe station right here.
So this is part 2 of Plan C.
Okay.
All right.
All right, Doobie.
It's your turn to shine.
Okay, follow me.
Our leader.
Oh, no.
She had to research part 2.
And I was... Oh, the guy's right there.
We gotta... Oh, I hear him!
I hear him!
Okay, don't worry.
I'll bait them.
I'll be a hero.
Oh my god.
That's right.
Don't worry.
I got this, guys.
Oh!
Wait, where did he go?
Guys, I lost him!
You lost him?
I don't know where he went!
Hello.
Oh, hey.
Oh, hang on.
I don't know where he went.
Hey, I'm looking for the room that has all the canisters down here that we did when we first did this.
Oh.
The room with green lines.
I didn't research that part.
I left it to you.
No, no, no, no.
It's already a part that we did.
It's just I need to find it.
Isn't it too- isn't it for up there to the right and then left?
No, it's right to the left.
Ah!
There he is!
Oh, I found it!
I found it!
Okay, so we have to take these upstairs.
Wait, we have to take these upstairs?
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah.
Um, he's right there?
He's here!
Oh, he is!
Oh, don't worry!
It's like dead by daylight!
Got you guys!
Okay, he's coming back!
Okay, she's dead.
Who's dead?
Um, she's dead.
Alright, this is it!
This is dead by daylight!
Right here!
Okay, that's- I got you.
I'm a hero.
Where'd he go?
Okay.
I'll just bait him.
Guys, push the thing!
He's on me!
Okay.
Well...
What?
Where did- Where did she come from?
Where- Where did she come- Where did she come- Where did- Wait, what?
Where- Where did she even come from?
Hello?
I'm here.
Hi.
Hello.
He just walked that way.
Oh, wait.
Have you just been hiding there?
The entire time?
Not the entire time.
I just hid here now.
Why'd you shut the door?
I'm trying to put... Okay, I think Mimi and Doobie are dead, so we have to go back.
Okay.
Bye-bye Mimi.
Get me out of here.
I'm pretty sure they're dead.
I think so too.
Hello!
Oh, yes, alright.
I pushed it a little bit.
I know where to loop her.
I think there's an easier way to go upstairs.
It's like right by the room.
Yeah, it's right here.
It's right here.
And then you push it from here.
Is he over there?
I don't know.
But it's right here.
This is where you push upstairs.
I hear him.
He's here.
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We gotta bring the janitor right here.
Yeah.
Okay.
What do we got?
Okay, he's chasing the green women.
Oh.
Take it off.
Alright, I'll... we're going for it.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, push this... this way.
Okay, I'm pushing.
I'm pushing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Greens, do your job.
Okay.
Wait, where is he?
Oh!
Okay.
Mimi, you got him?
Alright.
Is she alive?
Okay, I'm pushing it up.
There's two more canisters, man!
Push those!
I got one of them upstairs.
Okay.
But I don't know where to go after that.
Oh.
Okay.
Is that all of them?
Nope, there's no...
Oh.
Yeah, there we go.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, wait, wait.
Let's see if Mimi is...
Oh.
Hey!
What the hell?
Wait, Doobie, let's see if Mimi died or not.
Because I don't think she's alive.
What?
Are we gonna save?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I think it'd be good too.
Yeah, I had a feeling she was dead.
Alright.
Let's follow Doobie.
Her sacrifice is not in there.
Alright, so...
What I...
Realize...
He ha...
It like pushes the monster away.
Oh!
Nice.
He teched.
So...
Hopefully that guy doesn't come up here and then we just push these into the right spot.
Okay, I'll grab this one.
It might go backwards, though.
Um...
Okay.
I'm scared.
Wait, where are we supposed to go?
Somebody should get in between the canisters and then...
Yeah, yeah, I'm in between it.
Wait, actually, you should be in for it and I'll be back.
Cause...
Cause you know where to go.
Ah, he's coming!
Look!
Shoot!
Oh gosh.
I'm panicking.
I don't think they know where...
They don't know where they are.
They're still alive.
This way is the safe place.
Yeah, yeah.
Hello, we're back.
Okay, it only works in the hallway, I guess.
Okay.
We'll wait for him to pass.
Then we'll go back.
Okay.
Go for that guy.
Someone has to bait him out of here.
I saw you.
I saw him run fastest!
Alright.
Let's go.
Somebody lead him away.
Probably not me cause my shift key is not working.
Okay.
Yeah, someone, I need to push this.
He's here!
Okay, okay, guys.
Finally, we gotta lead him away!
Oh, it's okay.
He's trapped too.
Oh no.
It's okay.
It's just mid!
Ah!
Okay, that was...
I would say that that was on me.
That was on...
That was karma.
Right there.
That was 100% karma.
I believe, I believe in Doobie.
Alright, round two!
Round two!
One of the canisters is in there.
Okay.
We did it!
Alright, I'm pushing it with you.
Where do we push the other one?
Push, push, push, push.
I think we have to go...
I see a red line, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll go for that one.
Okay.
Is that this side?
Is it...
It's over here in this corner.
Oh, over here.
No, no, there's one more over here.
No, no, no, it's this way, it's this way.
Go this way?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, see?
We got it!
Ayy!
Yeah, ayy!
Last one's here, last one's here.
Oh, I hear, I hear.
Yo, yo, yo!
I believe, I believe.
Yay!
Wee-hoo!
Yeah, let's go save.
Okay.
Go save, go save!
I've got the dynamite!
Let's get in here, I forgot.
Uh, you can go this way.
No, no, no!
We do not go that way.
We do not go that way!
Is it this way?
Yeah, I think it's this way.
Is this the dead end?
Oh wait, I can place it now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe there's a save point over there.
Oh... Oh nice, nice, nice, nice!
There's gotta be a save point right here.
Oh yeah, there is!
Wait, we have a gun?
No, it's COVID.
Okay, Mimi's still alive.
Oh.
Because we all saw Mint die.
Yeah, yeah.
Yes.
This stuff doesn't kill us?
No, no.
It's where the orange or the COVID orbs.
Hello?
Oh, yes.
All right, now we can get... Wait, is this a new area?
Yeah, new area.
I don't know what to do past here, but we'll figure it out.
I... I... Remembers.
Oh.
Whoa.
Oh, it's your wife, Mint.
Right, she's... Oh my gosh.
Stranger lady.
Yeah, read us the dialogue for us.
You actually made it.
That horned beast had it out for you, a real nasty piece of work.
And don't even get me started on that worm.
Woodworm.
Yeah, Woodworm.
Good job not dying.
Yeah, we totally didn't die.
Zero deaths, guys.
Oh, that's all.
Oh, oh, really?
That was not very informative.
Zero deaths, zero deaths.
All right, that was my plan and that's all I got.
What do you have?
Wait, he has no head.
Oh, no.
Wait, I think we can put something here, no?
Is that the alien from the, you know, the Mexico alien?
Yeah, the...
I bet if we swap the other team you guys had with an orange, we could give this guy the...
Yeah, we give him the orange.
All right, there has to be...
Oh.
What does this say?
Loosed.
Loosed?
Okay.
Um, so we don't have a part three of this plan.
That was the extent of our research.
Yeah.
We have to find the electrical box.
That's all I know.
We're almost done.
Oh, this is that one area we've got.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is...
So this is...
This area is the new area.
I wonder if we have to take the canisters from up there, down here, probably.
No, we haven't fully explored this area, though.
Wait, there's another TV with no head.
Yeah.
There's...
I think this is where we came from.
Uh, yeah.
Do we go to the...
Is there another area here?
Okay, it's closed on the other side.
There'd be...
To the right?
Do we explore everything?
We didn't think we'd make it this far.
Not gonna lie.
We...
I did not think this far.
Oh, no.
Hello.
Um...
Do we explore everything in...
In this area?
I...
Feel like there's something we missed.
Yeah, I think we missed an area.
I'm pretty sure.
Where's the second floor?
Is this the second floor?
Do we go this way?
Yeah, this is the second floor.
Wait, we didn't go this way, guys.
Oh, yeah.
Over here.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
The warms scared me.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Nothing here.
It's just an empty room.
There's so many rooms here.
Oh, this is a...
Oh, this is a circle.
This is a circle.
Oh, we opened...
Oh, yeah.
We need the gun.
We should go to the...
Oh, we gotta go...
Go to the third floor.
Wait, isn't that other area that opened up?
We could go back.
Let's get to the third floor and grab the gun.
Maybe we should save that one.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Grab gun.
Save him?
Okay.
We go here.
There's a gun on the third floor?
Yeah, yeah.
The vending machine?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
See?
We're sinking with portals now.
Why is this guy here, though?
I'm scared of him.
I think he, like, came from...
Where...
Where did he go?
By the...
Like, what happened to him?
Yeah, um...
You get the gun, and I'll grab the lamp.
Okay.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I'll light our paths now.
We got this, guys.
We're gonna save the moon.
We need our tidal waves.
The other side.
This way.
Yeah, all the way to the end.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
I'm lighting the path.
Oh my god, that's scary.
You guys forgot that was...
What?
I thought someone just died!
Right below!
It was so dark.
Oh my god!
Oh, nice.
Wait, there's a little hole here.
Go in there.
Yeah, go in this little hole.
Maybe it'll be a safe hole.
Oh, there's more stairs here.
It's over on this side.
Orange heads cannot hear.
Oh!
So they can't...
It's the orange head.
It's the...
It's the orbs.
The COVID orbs.
Oh!
Wait, why is the...
Why is that guy here?
Oh, there's a TV here!
I found a TV here!
Oh!
Put it on his head!
Where is he?
He's on the bottom floor.
I mean, the next floor.
Here, this way, this way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
You lead the way.
We can...
Okay, watch out.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
We can go for him.
Oh, uh...
Over here?
Yeah, yeah, there he is.
Here's one.
Talk to us.
Hello.
Hello, guys.
He's alive!
We did it.
Oh, he's sad.
He's happy.
Yeah.
Oh, hello?
Excuse me.
You said, oh.
Hey.
Hey, hi.
It seems you're not infected.
The little black liquid creatures didn't catch you.
But I remember the times before the moon was brought here.
Back then, there were no creatures.
Everything was just empty.
Oh.
He's gone.
So the moon is evil.
The moon is evil.
We should save.
Yeah, we should save.
Okay, right here.
Wait, wait, wait.
Not here.
I'm spreading misinformation.
Okay.
Alright, let's go back to the...
You're not a little creature, though.
Let's go back to that area.
Wait, is it this way or the other way?
I think it was the other way, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, it was this way.
It was the shortcut.
Hi.
That's okay.
Yeah, this was another area I opened.
But I think it's the place we've been before.
Yeah.
And then...
We go...
Oh, do you hear that?
Do we drop down?
Oh!
Why not?
Uh...
You can go up the stairs if you go that way to the...
Where's the stairs?
How do I get back?
Wait, where are we before?
Wait, what you said?
Was there almost an elevator here?
I don't remember.
I...
I'm so lost.
I don't know.
Wait, where are the stairs?
I don't...
Where does this go to?
Oh, it's the laboratory.
Oh, they went the right way.
Wait, how do we get back?
They said there were stairs.
We lied to.
How do we get back?
Guys, we don't know where the stairs are.
Wait, is this like the very beginning?
Yeah, I remember this.
Yeah.
This is it.
Is it?
Yeah.
Remember we did the...
Wait, yeah.
I don't think this is it.
Wait.
What?
The only...
The only way forward is...
Is death.
If we die...
If we die, they'll revive us.
I believe in them.
Actually, we don't know where...
They don't know where the safe point is.
Weren't they just at the safe point?
Oh no, where did they go?
We can't even die!
Oh no!
This game won't even let us die!
Okay.
Maybe...
Oh!
Maybe it's the other way that we didn't go.
I believe in this, Nini.
Yeah, there was...
There, there, there!
They found it!
Okay, we have to die.
Okay.
Wait, this way...
Maybe?
Did you find it?
Oh!
That's where we can die!
Sweet!
Oh!
You came after me!
Okay.
Wait, it's only two of me.
Wait.
Oh!
One of the players should die.
Yay!
We did it!
Oh my gosh!
Okay, you guys figured it out.
Covid.
He's here.
There's another guy over here.
So be careful.
Okay.
One of us leads them away.
Alright.
Wait, wait.
There's a door!
Doobie!
Right here!
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
It's scary.
Wish I could smash those orange heads.
Oh!
That's another...
Shortcut?
Oh!
I'm so...
No!
I've never been here!
It was so close.
Throw that guy!
Okay.
We have to unlock that area again.
Do you have the gun?
Leave it close, right?
Oh yeah.
Yeah, we should leave it close.
Yeah, you're right.
So true!
I have...
I have it.
Oh yeah, nice.
Okay, where do we go?
Oh, this way?
I think there's...
There's like the orange guy.
We gotta sneak faster.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, because he can't hear sound.
So we can sneak it.
Oh, I hear that guy breathing on the other side.
Does that mean he could see us?
Yeah, it will see you.
And he's fast.
He will get you.
I'm red.
It's okay.
I...
I fated them all away from everyone.
It's okay.
I fated them all away.
Oh!
They got lost!
Wait, she found the door!
The password is somewhere here.
Doofy, no!
We're all dead!
Doofy!
Oh, nice!
Good job, Doofy!
I heard...
Min's final words was like, Password is somewhere here!
Password?
Who killed me?
Who's...
Who's sloppy body?
Okay.
Our hero, Doofy.
Oh, it's a...
We can't look at them too long or the...
Our fans get angry.
Alright, Doofy, what's the plan?
Oh...
Doofy, you're muted!
No!
The video's muted!
I couldn't get the plan!
Oh no!
We can't get there!
Min and Doofy are alive!
Oh, she's gonna open that...
Door.
Maybe.
What's Min doing?
We'll never know what to do.
Min's just like, please die.
Oh, she's trying to figure out the path.
Oh, she's so smart.
Go, Doofy, go!
Okay.
Oh, we just need Min to press that button.
Min!
We were all dead.
I'm trapped!
I'm kinda trapped in here, though.
Wait, I don't think that was the way to go anyway.
It was back here, right?
Or is it...
Oh wait, no, it was here.
Doofy, have you found the path?
We gotta just find the password.
In there.
How about like, one of us bait them out, and then the others run around it.
You can, yeah, you can like, kind of...
Run past them.
Wait, but you know the path!
You know the path!
Ah!
I got a door!
Where am I?
Oh my god, I'm up here.
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
Okay.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Hey guys, hey!
Hey!
I opened the door... Wait, is every...
Wait...
Shoot.
No.
Okay.
I keep saying that, huh?
I got...
Oh, I hear this.
Oh my god, you're fucking on here.
Wait, I found the password!
I found the password!
Five, one!
One!
Okay, guys, take a picture.
Chat, at chat, take a picture.
What does it say?
Let me see it.
Five, one, one, two, one, five, one.
Holy hell.
One.
Five, one, one.
Okay.
Okay, so, like, where's the safe box, though?
I know where it is.
Oh, okay.
Well, I have seen it with my eyes.
Okay, it's fine.
Nimi was a hero.
She, she's, I don't know if she's dead.
Watch out, watch out.
But she was a hero.
She's dead.
Okay, Nimi, I'm trying to get up!
Okay.
Nimi, I'm trying to get up!
Alright, let's just, let's just try for it.
Let's just try for it.
Where are you?
I think I hear her.
Is this it?
You're gonna die.
You're gonna die?
Okay.
Okay, we'll bring you back.
Oh, shoot.
Alright, we'll bring you back.
We found the password.
Nice!
Yeah, we need to know where the safe, the safe box is, though.
I, I, I, I...
I ran past it once.
Is this way too long?
It's a very long password.
No, it is very, very long.
Watch out, there's a little slime guy.
As long as we don't look at him, we'll be fine.
You guys know where the safe box is.
Min says she knows where it is.
Well...
Oh, guys.
One at a time, guys!
There can only be one.
Wait, I think she...
Did we lose her?
Did she die?
No, I don't think so.
Did she?
Oh, yeah.
I saw you two, like, stuff each other.
Yeah, you two are...
I didn't see anyone next to me, so...
I couldn't even tell.
Wait, Min, where...
I ran file!
Oh my god!
No,
he's capping!
That's illegal!
Wait, I think he's gone over here.
He's gone, he's gone.
Okay.
No, he's not.
Go, go, go, go, go!
One at a time!
Single file, everybody!
Oh my god!
The slime!
Run from the slime!
Oh my god!
Okay, is this the second floor?
Wait, no, this is the second floor!
I think so.
This is the second floor.
Is the safe in our...
in our...
room?
Or...
I've...
We've seen the safe before.
I remember.
There was one next to the map, but it didn't have this many digits.
There was...
There was something green that I was by, and that's where it said the password is close to here.
And it was in that room.
Oh, okay.
Where is it?
Think, Min.
Think!
It was upstairs, in that room, though.
Okay.
Okay, we can do this.
We just gotta have someone bait the guy again.
Oh!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
This is the first floor.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh...
Where was the save point here?
I don't remember.
Oh my god.
You little bastard.
Go, go, go, go!
Wait, I remember!
Um...
Oh my gosh.
Uh, over here, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Double kill.
There was one.
We got two of us.
The very first one we found.
Oh my god, there he is.
Oh, we're back!
Okay.
Yeah, he double killed us.
Yeah.
Okay, we got...
I left my password back there.
It's okay, chat remembers, right chat?
I don't know if we have to...
Okay, I got it.
Alright.
Think, guys.
Think.
Where is the save?
This is the first floor, so we have to go to the second floor.
Yeah, we have to go back up.
Oh, you're right.
Okay.
I believe in duty.
I hope this guy is not up here.
I know.
Okay, so where have you seen the save?
It was in this library room somewhere.
This is where I got the plate.
I got this here.
Oh.
Okay.
So...
One of us...
One of us will remember.
I think we have to go that way.
Yeah, there's no other way to go.
There's here!
Don't come over here!
Where
the fuck is that save?
Oh my god!
Where is it?
Oh, I lost everybody.
But that's okay.
Maybe I'll find the save.
Oh, I found...
Wait, no.
I didn't find it.
Okay, I collected the data.
Hello?
Is everybody alive?
Or is everybody dead?
Hello?
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know who's alive and who's not.
I'm so confused.
Oh my...
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god.
One of us is alive.
One of us is still alive.
Hello?
Hey.
Where are you?
I'm at the first save point.
Oh, I'm at...
The other save point.
Alright, I'll die or I'll go up there.
Alright.
I'm on the...
I'm like with all the TV people.
Okay, I'm gonna die.
Okay, did you find the save?
Guys, did she find it?
Did she find the save?
I don't know if she found it.
Someone is still alive.
Who is still alive?
Please...
Please just die for the cause.
Just die for us.
Oh, oh, they're dead.
Yay!
Okay.
Doobie, how did you do that?
Wait, what did...
What did she do?
I have my face between his cheeks.
Nice.
Okay.
Did you find the save?
You an alien man's ass.
I didn't find any save.
What about you?
You guys?
Oh, I didn't find anything.
No, we were dead for a while.
We've been dead for a while.
Okay.
What if somebody stays here so that we can revive?
And then somebody goes...
Oh!
You go!
Alright.
Okay, who wants to be the...
How do you do the emotes again?
I don't remember.
Oh, it's E?
Oh, I have an item on it.
Oh, gee.
I have an item on it.
Indian woman with the same bird.
Oh, gee.
Alright, who wants to be- I will go look for it.
But let me see the thing again.
Alright, who would be the driver of the driver in Phasma-phobia?
I'll sit here because my shift key sometimes doesn't work.
Oh, you gotta get a new keyboard.
Yeah.
Have you heard of the wooden keyboard?
It's pretty good.
You have to?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I guess you would need it.
Guys, you're going... I think they went the wrong...
It was supposed to be that.
I thought the library was the other way.
Yeah, I thought the... Oh, no, wait.
It is that way, then you go up the... Is it?
How did I... No, I... Oh, I opened a shortcut.
That's why it's easier.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
That's why I said, guys.
Oh, yeah, over there?
Yeah.
It's over there, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, they went the...
They definitely went the wrong way, right?
I think it still opens up on that side.
No, they're coming back.
They went the wrong way.
Hey, guys.
Hey, you guys are going the wrong way.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
I can't believe what happened in front of me.
Why
is it always Doobie?
Why is it always Doobie?
Why does this always happen to her?
Oh, my God.
Oh,
my God.
Oh, my God.
The amount of times that's happened to her in the last two parts is actually crazy.
Goodbye, Doobie.
Goodbye.
You guys are going the wrong way.
I was like...
Oh, it's the Doobster.
Okay.
I guess I'm on Phasmophobia duty now.
Alright.
Gone too soon.
Poor Doobie.
I don't hear them at all.
So, I assume they're...
I don't hear screams.
They're okay?
Oh, where at?
Oh, I'm back here.
Hey, guys.
Where's... Where's Nimi?
Did she die?
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
Welcome back.
I... I... Well, go again.
Yeah, go again.
I somehow stopped it.
I don't know how.
Wait, you stopped the password?
Wait, you guys know where the safe is?
No, no, no.
Not the password.
I... The guy... He stopped chasing after me.
I don't know why.
Oh.
It was weird.
Like, I hid here.
Oh.
Maybe it's like the... The distance.
Alright.
I got you guys.
Okay, we gotta find the safe.
At chat, are we close to the safe?
I don't know!
You need to go through this.
Oh wait, this is a nice spot too.
Guys, we're... Alright.
Oh my god.
Where is the safe?
Like, I found this.
This is where we died.
And this is where we kept going past.
I'm gonna... We gotta split it up though, I feel like.
Oh, I'm safe.
Okay, they're chasing them.
I don't think they can go past this door.
I haven't seen it, but Min says she has, so...
Oh, I have to not look at them.
Oh my god.
Min says she saw it, so it's like somewhere here.
Unless we're at the wrong house.
Guys, is it here?
Is the safe even here, guys?
Or are we going the wrong way this entire time?
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
We've been like going the wrong way the entire time.
Oh, it is here.
Okay, at least we know it's here.
We're all relying on Min's memory right now.
Where the safe is.
Because she is the only one out of all of us that has seen it.
So I hope, I hope it's right.
Oh, I found it.
Guys.
What is it?
What's the number?
I found it.
Guys, I said, I said take a screenshot.
There's no eight.
Okay.
I know it started with five.
Five.
Guys, please.
Guys.
What have you had the screenshot?
Please.
I said someone take the screenshot.
Five.
One.
Two.
Oh my god.
Guys, I have to post it again.
Because some people are posting boob.
Five.
One.
Two.
Guys, please.
Someone had it.
Someone had the entire thing.
One.
Five.
Oh my god.
It's so fast.
One.
Oh my god.
It's too fast.
I can't.
Guys, please.
One.
Two.
Oh, I did it.
I got the electrical board.
I don't know how to get out though.
Hello?
Oh my god.
I'm fucking trapped.
Doobie.
Where are you?
I told you I saw it.
I told you.
All right, it was green.
You should have heard of my song.
Five.
One, one, two.
One, five, one.
Where my chat was just boobs and boobies.
I wanted like one or two people had the right code.
But my chat kept spamming boob.
So I couldn't get it.
So what does this go to?
Um, it's on the outside.
Remember the...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
So there's just one more electrical board.
Yeah, we just need one.
How do we get downstairs?
That's a good...
The other one must be in the other save box.
By the map.
Oh!
Oh, what's the password?
This is where the worm is.
Oh, wait.
You guys, you have to go this way.
No, no, there's another way.
Yeah, why are we going this way?
Why did we chose the path of the most resistance?
I'm just exploring.
I don't know.
I heard that right behind me.
Who died?
Nobody.
Well, it wasn't saving.
Somebody.
Wait, I remember we unlocked the door that went downstairs.
Did we?
No, we didn't...
We didn't blow it up, did we?
No, we did.
We did.
We unlocked there.
Yeah, see?
Oh, just kidding.
Yeah, yeah, see?
She knows the way.
I'm so lost.
It's here.
This is where the thing was.
See?
The moon is literally right below us.
The moon, free the moon, free the moon.
One last...
It's one last task.
We have one last thing to do.
Do you want to try and get the secret way to the basement?
Nah, that's not that important, right?
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
It's helping the guy.
Yeah.
Okay, we need to find the safe.
So true.
True.
Yeah, I know.
All he...
We gave him a TV and then he left, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
He was like, see you suckers.
They knew we're supposed to follow him.
Like, where did he go?
Did he just float off?
Yeah, he did.
He said there's like a secret way to the basement outside, but whatever.
Yeah, we don't need to know that.
We don't need to know about...
So where do we find the password for the safe box northwest of the ground?
Does anyone know their cardinal directions?
Uh...
Never eat sausage waffles.
Oh, the map!
Maybe the scanner has a, uh...
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, let's go get this.
Look at the blue thing on the map.
Wait, you can pull up the map?
How?
Yeah, there's tab.
Wait, I totally tried that this time.
Oh my god!
Wait, there was a map this entire time?
I've...
Wait, what is the button?
Tab?
Tab!
Why didn't you tell us this?
I just...
I thought I tried it last time and it didn't work.
Why is there a pin on the map?
Yeah, that's what I'm looking at.
Yeah, maybe that's the next...
That's the next, uh...
Uh...
Yeah.
It's right here.
We can go check it out.
All right.
Like, it's right here.
No?
Wait, I can't believe we had...
It's inside?
Is it?
Is it the way to the basement?
Oh!
It's the way to the basement!
This is what we did there!
We figured it out!
Yeah!
It was just marked on the map.
We have to find the TV in the basement.
Wait, I don't want to be first.
I'm scared.
What if the...
Okay, but it's either first or behind.
Or the last.
Wait, where's the TV head?
Is it safe?
Every time Doobie said it looks safe, the guy shows up, so...
I found...
I found him!
There's a guy over here.
Oh!
It's back up ahead.
Better bring a light.
Oh.
Okay, so we have to go forward for the TV head.
It's...
Yeah.
I think it's in here.
Okay.
Oh, there is?
Yeah, he's right there.
But he can only get...
Oh, he walked away.
See?
He walked away.
Oh, wait, there's a guy over here, too.
Maybe it's this way.
No.
It's alright.
One of us will die, and then maybe...
Yeah.
Maybe it's...
Oh.
I don't...
What?
Did you hear that?
Someone...
Stop staring here.
Yeah.
Someone's breathing heavily.
I'll lead him!
I'm bleeding him!
Oh, it's the meow meows!
Hey, she's right behind us.
Oh, it's here!
It's at the laboratory.
We got the secret, um, the shortcut.
Oh, I don't...
Oh...
I believe in you.
Okay.
There must be a TV here.
Oh my god, it's actually like a labyrinth right here.
Oh, hey, there's a save terminal here.
I found a save here!
Hello!
Wait, I found more stuff here!
Oh my god.
Oh, hey, TV head!
Oh, you're here!
According to note here...
I know it's not if they're not far from here.
Pretty sure it leads straight there.
Let's go!
Oh, I found this man.
I talked to him.
It says talk to...
Oh, follow TV head!
We gotta follow him!
Wait, where do you go?
I can't see anything.
Wait, wait, did you...
Wait, we lost him.
Oh no, he's in here, here, here, here, here!
Oh, okay.
This way, this way, this way.
I'm following him real close.
I'm following him, yep.
I know, look at him go.
I know.
Little alien.
Just a little guy.
What did he want him to go to?
Maybe he'll find the password.
I swear to god, if the monster is like, literally right behind us while we're slowly slinking along.
He's right behind me.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Oh wait, he led us to an elevator.
Oh.
Is Doobie alive?
I don't think so.
Hey, hey, we're almost at the laboratory.
Oh, okay.
Oh, eh?
Oh, that's the secret entrance to the laboratory.
Okay, this is the most convoluted entrance to the laboratory.
Are
you gonna perform surgery on this man?
We're gonna perform surgery on this man.
Wait, this is...
This room does not feel safe.
Oh.
What was that?
Is he gonna kill us?
Is he the final boss?
I don't, I don't trust him.
Look at him.
He's just smiling at us.
Just a little guy.
Is there Covid in here?
No?
There's a safe station!
Oh, nice, nice.
But do we just follow him first?
I think so.
Yeah, just follow him for now.
But there's a giant ass button.
Oh.
Okay, let's say...
Let's get Doobie here.
Oh.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
Oh, he wants the orange down there.
Oh, no, there's a...
Covid head!
Don't do it!
Okay, wait, wait, let's...
Let's get Doobie here first.
Guys.
All right.
Yeah!
All right, who's good at...
Who's good at crane games?
Where is this?
Wait, where is the grabber?
Oh, it's a game pad.
Yeah.
Oh, I see it!
Over there!
Over there, you gotta move it.
Oh, okay.
Who's good at...
Who's good at this?
Not me.
I didn't even see what's moving.
I fluff it every time.
Okay.
Keep going left.
Oh, all right.
Left.
You're good.
All right.
Tell me you wanna stop.
You're good.
Stop.
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
Oh.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Just a little bit over to the left more.
You have to go back more.
Back?
Okay.
Yeah.
Stop.
It didn't stop.
Wait a little to the left.
Oh, I have to press it again.
Okay.
Tell me when to stop.
Stop.
To the left a little.
A little bit more, I think.
Try now.
All right.
Oh.
Go for the back.
Come on.
A little more to the left.
And then...
A little back.
Back?
Yeah.
Yeah, a little back.
Okay.
And a little more to the left.
Right?
Left?
Guys, left.
Oh my god.
Is it even open?
Open?
Okay, guys.
First off, is it open?
I don't know.
Okay.
Oh, left.
Left.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
More left.
More left, more back.
Okay.
Is this good?
Oh my god, how precise is this?
Are you serious?
Guys, I swear to god, if this was not open and... Wait, what?
Are we not?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh wait, left, left.
Stop.
Stop, you have to press it again.
You have to press it again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Did I get it?
Oh, wait!
Do me!
It was our perspective.
Oh my god.
I couldn't see it.
Oh, and then we have to pull it back to him.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh yeah, put it on and put it on.
Wait, he's gonna die.
I need to use the bathroom.
Someone else do it.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Wait, you're gonna die, Doki.
You're right here.
Wait, it's gonna touch you.
Doki, why did you stop right there?
Just let her die.
Yeah.
What is it?
That's as far as it goes.
Yeah, it's as far as it goes.
Maybe talk to him and then he's like, oh.
Wait, I can grab it.
Okay.
Oh.
I don't think this is gonna be good.
Talk to him.
This is a good orange.
This is what we need.
We'll be able to install it in the operating room.
We are performing surgery.
Doki will follow us.
I'll come back.
Yeah, we'll pick her up.
We'll pick her up.
What is it?
I have a crane operator.
I'm back.
Did we do it?
Hello.
Yeah.
What happened?
Oh, we're...
To the operating room.
This way.
Oh, okay.
I believe.
Oh, hey.
Wait.
You guys are just carrying the head, just like that.
It's time to replace the head.
I'm about to perform so...
We're gonna do a surgery on the alien!
It's like the Mei Mei say.
Okay, here I go.
First, you need to remove the TV.
Then you put the orange in its place.
Why does he want this?
I'm ready to be a TV head with no TV.
Let's hope it all goes right.
It's gonna be built differently, so I'm gonna be like the other one.
Oh my god, he's T-posing!
He's... he's T-posing!
I'm taking... wait, I can't... can someone else take the head?
Yeah.
Yeah, take... yeah, there you go.
I took it.
I'm applying the item.
Oh my god, that's how he be...
Wait, I think he'll be... isn't he evil now?
Yes.
Maybe?
No, he seems cool.
Yeah, he's cool now.
Oh, another orange head.
Oh, he's... he won't talk to me.
Oh?
Dot, dot, dot.
Dot, dot, dot, dot.
Dot, dot?
Maybe we need to bring him something?
Oh, he's talking to me.
What the hell?
Oh, he didn't like you.
Oh.
I think I got an orange for a head now.
Yay!
Some feel... some reason I feel drawn upward.
That's unusual.
Yeah, that's weird.
Maybe somebody else has to talk to him now.
Oh, okay.
You're turning me.
Okay.
I think I might be able to try something.
I'll be in the courtyard of the main building.
Where's the courtyard?
Wait, guys, remember this...
The other dead... dead alien?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Maybe he'll tell us the codes.
Okay, we just got...
I don't think we can open that.
We gotta find the...
So, we gotta go to the courtyard.
And then, also, we gotta give the other dead alien this other TV.
Yeah.
That was so far away.
Okay, yeah, there must be a...
How did we get down here?
The guide led us here.
Wait, you're right.
We don't have a flashlight.
I don't remember.
Oh, is there an elevator to the main area?
I don't know.
Wait, maybe...
Maybe?
Okay, we save.
We save.
We never went this way.
Maybe this way tells us.
Oh, yeah.
Here we can buy...
No.
I got a flashlight.
Wait, there's a...
There's a basement, guys.
Right there.
The flashlight.
There's a basement.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, this goes down to the first floor.
Maybe we die if we want.
Yeah, yeah.
And then, from there, we can take the elevator to go to the first floor.
Wait, was there nothing here?
Oh.
Can I take this?
There's nothing here.
Oh, there's...
Yeah.
How mysterious.
Oh, it is...
Oh, yay shortcut.
Oh, this is so handy.
Yeah.
There's a little goo, guys.
So let's go.
Yeah, we don't look at them.
She can't get in the elevator, right?
No.
No, no.
No one can get in the elevator.
No, none of the aliens can get in.
They're not loud.
Was it the...
Third floor.
Third floor?
Yeah, we're in the first floor right now.
Okay.
We're doing it, guys.
We just need...
It's a panel.
I wanna watch Cartoon Network.
No, I'm a...
I'm a Nickelodeon kid.
Dexter's lab is on.
Come on.
First floor.
Wait, what are we doing here?
Oh, the other elevator.
Yeah.
Alright.
We're almost there.
What are we doing?
Uh...
Wait, which one do we do first?
The TV or the courtyard?
Um...
Closer.
Yeah.
I think...
I think the TV's closer, right?
Well, I mean, we have to go to the courtyard first, to be fair, but...
Yeah.
Maybe the TV?
Just in case.
The TV would be a little more dangerous.
Is it the first floor or the basement?
Uh...
Basement?
I don't...
Remember.
It'll come back to us.
Wait, we have a map.
Why are we asking each other this?
There's no map data.
Oh...
I think it's only for outside.
Oh, wait, someone said first floor.
Let's go do that.
Dude, there's just one guy.
Um, excuse...
It's two guys.
Uh, one is a member and one isn't.
It's so loud.
Oh, okay.
Oh, it's here!
And then we go to the second floor.
Wait.
No, see?
Oh, he's here.
Where's the courtyard?
There he is.
Yeah, there he is.
He's waiting for us.
Yeah.
Is he just gonna float away?
He walked out of the stairwell?
I know what happens to him.
Yeah.
He's sitting outside.
It's so cute.
Aw.
I just...
Hey!
I think I'll be better there.
Feels like I could jump.
Really?
What's stopping me?
Don't jump!
Just the thought of how long I'll keep falling.
That scares me a bit.
Aw.
I'll talk to him, I guess?
I'll tell him.
Yeah?
Oh, thank you.
I couldn't have done any of this without you.
It's time for me to go.
No!
His people need him!
Wait!
There he goes!
Oh!
Did we do the right thing?
Oh, seven in the chat!
Wait!
It says visit the operating room in the laboratory again.
Okay, do we do the...
I guess we should go to the operating room, right?
That's where we just were.
Yeah, but...
I think so.
But that's his next...
I think we should do the TV guide first, so I see...
I think this progresses the story.
And I think the other one was like a bonus side quest.
Oh...
Yeah, I think so too.
Yeah, that's fair.
Yeah, so we should do the side quest for just to see.
Cause I think it's a reward for completing it.
Okay!
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, me too!
Me too!
Cool one!
It was like that song, what was that?
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
What is this?
Is this the...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then...
Wait, where's the elevator?
Because it's here.
Oh, here, here.
Okay.
Yeah, and then...
Laboratory.
Yeah, we're doing it guys.
Got it.
His final message was for us to go to the operating room.
Yeah.
Maybe there's like a tracker on him.
Yeah, maybe.
Do you think he... Do you think... Like, do you think he's still floating in space right now?
Yeah.
He's probably not there yet.
He's going to the moon.
Another moon.
Wait, why are we following Mint?
Does she know where to go?
It's the elevator.
Oh.
That was stupid.
I was gonna say, does she actually know... I don't remember what floor it was.
It was first floor.
Oh, it was on the first floor?
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
On the first floor?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Am I holding the TV while doing this?
Yeah, you are.
Whoa.
And then I'm right here to the... Where are you?
Pretty gnarly, guys.
Gnarly.
Is this opening stairway?
Do you see it?
Yeah.
I don't know.
This way?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember.
And then there's the operating table.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know.
But what do we have to do here again, I wonder?
Uh... I think he just... He gave us something.
Yeah, yeah, see?
Final message.
Oh!
What's it say?
Place the... Oh!
Place the crystal inside to upgrade it.
The upgrade crystal is capable of destroying the oranges.
Oh!
That would be huge!
Wait, where's... That would be huge!
Yeah, booby.
I'll just wait here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All the way over here.
Like, only one of you guys have to do that.
I'll wait here, guys.
Because my chat also died, so I gotta fix that.
It died on my end.
Yeah, I knew this was, like, a bonus mission thing.
Because that's a... Because it's... Like, we got an achievement for it, so it was a side...
Okay, guys.
How do we do the...
Find the... Guys, please.
We just need to find the password for the safe box, guys.
We're killing all his friends, though.
Oh!
What if he dies up there?
Yeah, come on!
It's okay, he's in space.
Wait, so where do I put it?
In the box, right?
Place the crystal inside to upgrade it.
Yeah, yeah.
This box.
Oh.
I don't think that's the right...
Oh!
Oh, it upgraded.
It's upgraded.
Cool!
Yay!
Yeah, I have the TV.
Also, we got, like, a special little thing to...
I'd take it!
Yeah!
Alright.
Let's go find the TV.
Are they dead, then?
Let's see.
They were down here.
Oh.
Well, we have to take... We have to, like, go up towards them, right?
To kill it?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
It's, like, AOE.
Oh, wait, let's save.
Let's save.
Let's save, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm coming, I'm coming!
Yay!
Okay.
Okay, now we can go through the last password easily.
Um...
Yeah, we'll be able to walk through that, like, whole area.
Yeah.
But where is the password, though?
I don't know.
Oh, yeah.
Please do...
Wait, no, we have a map now.
We have a map.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
That's true, that's true.
Any truers?
Okay.
We got this.
Everything's coming together.
I believe.
Super Cheeto.
Alright.
I got my TV.
We got our Cheeto.
Um...
We're ready to game.
Good night, right?
Yeah.
I'm ready for our LAN party, guys.
We're still upgrading permanent.
We have to do it every time.
Oh, we're not gonna lose it, so we don't have...
Yeah.
Exactly.
Oh, yeah, it's first floor.
Okay.
The TV head guy is on the second floor.
So we got...
Whoa!
Go, guys.
Woo!
Okay.
Does anyone know how to get to the second floor?
Um, we got...
Maybe we could go from the court...
From the annex, right?
Uh...
Oh, here, here, here.
Yeah.
Found it.
Okay.
Uh, TV head.
Oh, we're gonna go kill them?
No, no, no.
We're gonna give him the last alien the TV.
Yeah, let's give the last...
Yeah.
The other alien the TV first, I think.
Okay.
Yeah, but where is he?
I don't remember where he was.
I remember the first guy was here, but...
Yeah, he's all the way up down here.
He's all the way down here.
He's right here.
Oh, okay.
Hello, TV man.
Take the TV.
Hello.
Do you want an orb too?
Hi.
Oh, he's happier.
Yeah.
Oh.
Hello.
Uh, hello?
You kind of remind me of something.
Did you even know creatures like you pissed off the little black liquid creatures?
What?
They got all bothered and now, well, this is happening.
Yeah, what, me?
Yeah, I meant you.
And, uh, you sort of plugged the TV into me.
We didn't ask for his consent.
Now I can't even look away from all this weirdness.
He's not grateful at all.
He didn't help me.
Where did he go?
Oh.
Look what you did.
You didn't ask for his consent.
To have a TV on his head.
You are the one holding the TV.
No.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Wait, we should go save over here real quick.
Oh, yeah.
That's true.
Oh, I hear him.
I hear him.
Wait, what kind of guy?
Like the Slenderman.
Yeah?
Yeah.
The one that always gets us.
Okay, now.
Look at the map.
Yeah.
Maybe we go to the courtyard would tell us.
Okay.
We mean the courtyard.
I mean the courtyard tell us.
Oh, the grounds.
Because it says the grounds.
So I assume it's outside.
Oh, northwest of the grounds.
Oh, there's like other guys over there.
Wait, how do we get...
I know that the...
There's the safety box is where the map was.
But I don't know where the password is.
Yeah, cause we need to...
Find the password for it.
It says northwest of the grounds.
So...
Maybe the...
Okay, guys.
We know our cardinal directions now, right?
Yeah.
Okay, so there's a staircase here.
Alright, let's go downstairs.
Just like here.
And then...
Alright.
We have a map now.
Where's northwest?
Oh, yeah.
I'm on somebody's...
Oh, that's where that building is.
Where that, uh...
Face guy.
Yeah, yeah.
Where the face guy is bothering us.
Alright.
And we know what to do.
We just gotta go northwest.
Oh, he's like right there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He goes through the gate, so be careful.
Oh, he does?
We'll wait for him to go back the other way.
There he goes.
Look at him go.
Wait, what are we...
We're looking for a password.
Yeah, it says northwest of the grounds.
Which one's northwest?
Is that north...
Could you just say, what is northwest?
I mean, where...
Where is northwest?
Uh-oh.
He's coming, he's coming.
Oh my god.
Guys, we gotta split up.
I think he's on me.
What have I done?
I didn't even hear her final words.
Did she die?
Let's stop left.
Okay.
So it's somewhere here.
It's somewhere here.
Let's split up, gang.
Are you alive?
I opened the door to the van.
Oh.
Yeah, this is the password.
We still need a fire...
Like, I mean...
This is the...
The safe.
Wait, hold on.
Wait, I'll wait for him to pass again.
Wait, is Mint alive?
Yeah, she's over there.
Oh, okay.
Mint, you can die now!
Wait, we should put our upgraded...
Crystal here, just in case.
I'll drop it.
I don't wanna die.
Okay, I'm gonna go to the van.
Okay.
Is that the password?
No.
Hold on, I'll tell ya.
I didn't get the password.
Wait, you got a special what?
Special book.
Freaking lame.
Aww.
Okay, we gotta still find the...
The password.
Oh!
Oh my god!
I know what the password is!
It's really dumb!
Oh my god, I'll show you later.
Okay.
Wait.
One of the numbers is three.
How do you know?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Come over here, guys.
I'll show you what I know.
What do you know?
Look down.
Oh my god!
One of it is three!
What is the other number?
What?
How do we know the order?
Oh, I'm so alive, everyone.
I'm so alive.
I'm still alive.
What is the password?
You guys done the password?
One of the numbers is three.
One of them was three.
I don't know what...
How did you do...
I didn't see how you saw what the number was.
If you go up to that tree and then you look down and there's a number three on it.
Do you think it's the five trees?
No.
Oh, there are five.
Oh my god.
Okay, so the three...
The third is...
Okay, wait.
This is one...
Okay, number two is three.
Okay.
Yeah, number two is three.
Oh my god, this is hellish.
Okay.
All right, guys, we got it.
Okay, I'm gonna go look for number one.
Okay, I'll look... let's split up, gang.
I'll look for number...
three.
I got number three.
Yes, he does.
Okay.
What's yours, Nimi?
How do you know what tree is...
Just follow your heart, Nimi.
Follow your heart.
Wait, is there which way is...
Okay, we all have to stick together to go to our area anyway.
And then we'll all split up.
All right.
No, no, no, it's on the other side.
It's on the other side of the gates.
It is?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, cuz there's only one tree.
Wait, is it?
No, there isn't any here, yeah.
Okay, is it on the other side?
I thought it was the...
I thought it was like here.
Is there any numbers here?
I'm following my own heart, but I think my heart is wrong.
Hello?
I don't see any numbers.
I know, is it?
You're crazy.
No, I did!
I saw it!
I swear to God!
Wait, I'll show you.
I'll show you, Dewi.
Come over here.
Okay, okay.
I'll show you.
No, I swear I'm not crazy.
I swear I saw it.
We all saw it.
We have to wait for this.
Maybe you have to shine the flashlight on it or something?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
My flashlight was not on.
Okay, they're looking...
I don't think he sees us.
Okay.
Okay, he sees me.
I'm gonna freak his out.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, we gotta get Mimi it back.
Hello.
Alright.
I can't find number one.
Okay, but you guys saw the number, right?
You guys saw my number, right?
What?
I'm not crazy, right?
Y'all saw it.
No, I didn't see it.
Okay, alright, come follow me.
We're all gonna see it together.
Maybe one person can only see one number on each tree.
Okay, all of us, do you see this number?
Oh!
I thought you meant the glowing tree.
Oh, three!
There's a three!
Okay, let's check all the normal trees in this area, then.
I knew I wasn't crazy.
I knew.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, straight, whatever direction.
This way, I was trying to find number one, but I couldn't find it.
It has to be the other side of the gate.
You think so?
Yeah, right?
No, I think it can't be, because it would be too easy.
Where would it be, then?
I don't... I don't know, I was looking over here.
I don't see any other number.
Yeah, it's like, it's here.
It is here.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, what?
Nine!
What's your number?
Where did you find it?
Or six?
Six or nine, right here.
Oh, oh.
Um, I think it's six.
I think it's six.
I think, I can't tell.
I can't tell either.
Oh, I missed it?
Oh my god, I don't remember what it was on the map.
I don't remember, I'm just gonna...
Maybe if I'm lucky, I'll find it on the floor.
I...
Maybe I'll just be very lucky.
And I'll find it.
Nine!
Alright.
Hey, I find the...
I found the number, so I contributed.
Alright.
We found two of them.
Wait, did...
Did it miss that?
Okay.
Thank you!
Let's see.
Which one was yours though?
Was it the one or the three?
Oh, it's either six or nine.
We don't know.
It's six, it's six.
Okay, yours is one.
It's six, okay.
Okay.
Okay, so...
Then three is like up ahead and...
Okay.
I pulled out my map.
Three is close to one and five is also...
They're in that kind of square little area.
If someone can lead the guy away, then...
I'll do it!
You will?
I believe in you!
Wait, where is he?
The hero!
Oh, he's over where we need to go.
Just kidding.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's right...
Somewhere here.
Or here?
There's one more we're missing.
And then one should be here, right?
Where was the five?
Oh, I found one!
I found one!
Nine!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's...
It's a nine or a six.
Okay, we'll figure that out later.
It's a six or a...
Oh my god, Doobie's still doing it!
Oh my god!
She's a hero, Doobie!
She's a hero!
Oh my god!
Doobie!
Where's Doobie?
Okay.
It's a six or a nine.
At the far end.
That would be the fourth digit.
Okay.
The fourth one?
Yeah, so...
I don't know...
Oh!
We did it!
Yay!
I think we beat the game!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
We can beat the game!
Wait, should we save again?
Oh yeah, we should save again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a good idea.
Good idea.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's go.
Let's go save the moon.
Get rid of the moon!
Get rid of the creatures!
Yeah!
Then we'll bring the...
We'll have two moons on Earth, guys!
Two moons!
Double the waves!
Just keep running!
Just don't...
Ignore this blood stick behind you.
Just keep running.
Okay, we're good.
Yeah, we're fine.
Wait, is this the one that we have to do inside?
The left door?
No, no, no.
It's out here.
Am I holding it still?
Yeah, I am.
Okay, I was like...
Where is it?
Oh, it's this one.
That's right.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited!
Ready?
Wait, wait.
Wait, I don't know actually if this ends the game, but...
I hope so!
Alright.
Not that I'm not enjoying my time spent with you all.
Yeah, I was like...
We just want to see the moon!
Yeah!
I'm going in.
Come on!
It won't let me.
Oh?
Open the hatches?
Is it gonna come out?
Wait, it's coming!
It's coming out!
The moon is rising!
Oh!
Oh, sorry guys, team...
Get on!
Oh my god, you're right!
So are you guys team Jacob or Edward, guys?
Are you...
Oh.
Obviously.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Oh!
Look, it's sucking the creatures in!
It's sucking the creatures in!
Oh!
Wait!
My girlfriend wants to talk to me.
Sorry, hold on.
Wait, why did the moon even glow?
Wait!
Guys, it's not over.
Is this a moonrise?
Oh!
That's what she just said.
We got everything done, didn't we?
No!
It's also...
There's an energy dome.
Oh my god!
We were so close!
But it says two out of two.
And one out of one.
Oh, I think it's everywhere we've been to.
And then we just like...
Okay.
Oh, we...
Wait, what's the energy?
We just press the button.
Oh!
Look at the map!
Oh, the valves!
Oh, that's what they are for.
Yeah.
So there's one...
Inside.
Inside here?
Yeah.
But you gotta be careful.
Oh, so that's not too hard.
Okay.
Okay, one of us has...
Oh!
Our wife will save us.
Did he save us?
Oh!
The brain.
I got it though.
Did I do it?
I can do the same point over here.
The first one, I think.
I did it.
I was a hero.
Wait, open the map.
Yeah.
My...
Right here.
Oh!
We're back.
Okay, I got...
I got one of the valve.
My game crashed.
My game crashed!
Kept putting it back up.
Okay, it's okay.
We saved though.
We saved.
But we saved, so we shouldn't be...
So we...
Are they still in game?
Did they all got kicked out?
They all got kicked out.
I hope that they get kicked out.
Alright.
Oh, oh!
Wait.
Okay, okay.
Alright.
There we go.
Okay.
We can at least be our colors now.
At least...
Guys, at least we can be our colors now.
Hello?
My game actually crashed.
Oh my god.
It was the moon.
It's okay.
For the...
We can at least be our colors now.
Oh!
I didn't get to change!
Wait.
What happened to the numbers?
They changed.
Did they change?
Yeah, they did.
No, no.
It's the same.
It's...
102.
Yeah, the valve is here.
Mine was messed up then.
Before.
I was excited about me and my color.
Yeah.
That's why I pressed start.
Wait, where's that?
There's one in a...
There's one like right here.
But how do we get to one of these?
Wait.
Oh yeah, it's right there.
It's glowing.
How do we get there?
We just go over here, I think.
We just go in, right?
Oh.
You're so smart.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Don't worry guys.
I'll get this way.
Oh, the second floor and basement.
So...
Wait, I'm just announcing two out of two.
Oh.
Is it supposed to be like this the whole time?
Guys, we gotta go...
Go to the second floor or the basement.
Okay.
It's this way.
I believe in a...
Wait, is it this way?
Wait, I didn't see anything.
Wait, where...
Where is...
Wasn't this the basement over here?
No.
Yeah, where's this...
Where's the...
The door for the basement?
I...
Isn't it right here?
Oh, here, here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right here.
Okay.
We found one over here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Watch out, that guy.
Oh, hi.
Hey.
Guys, we never found the map data for the basement.
Oh no.
Oh.
Is it this?
Wait, but it's like right by the...
I remember seeing it right by the door.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Basement or basement two?
I did basement two because you said second floor basement.
Oh.
Oh, it is.
Second floor basement.
See?
Open the map.
Oh.
This way.
Okay, be careful.
Oh, we have to go past...
We have to go past...
Oh, he's right there.
He's right there.
Wait, no.
We go forward.
Run past it!
Alright, we'll go forward.
We can get it.
Okay.
I got it!
I wonder if she's dead.
I wonder if she's...
Nibi, thank you for being a hero, Nibi.
Oh, okay.
Thank you for both heroes.
All heroes.
Yeah!
Yeah, heroes.
Heroes in grey!
Guys, heroes never die, guys.
True.
Okay, second floor.
So now...
Second floor.
Oh, it's like right here.
Oh, easy.
Yeah.
Alright.
We should've bought the orange thing.
Oh, yeah.
We should've...
We left it.
Got it?
I thought the game was...
And then we go to the moon?
We got it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was so close.
We did it!
yz yz yz yz we missed it!
We're gonna miss it!
Come on, we're gonna fuck!
OOOOOX!!!
There it goes!
Oh my god, it's beautiful!
It's so beautiful!
Oh my god, it will rise to a level where you can approach it and take flight.
Wait, do we have to go to the ceiling?
The roof?
What?
That's what the manager just said.
How do we get to the roof?
Uh...
It's going to the moon.
The moon will push...
Outside, this way, this way, this way.
Remember, it's the meow, the meow-meows.
The little cats.
Meow-meows.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, maybe not the meow-meows.
Yeah, you're going the wrong way.
Oh my god.
Okay, there's someone else lead.
Yeah, someone with the map.
Nini, we nominate you.
It's this way.
Right?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
In here, this way.
That way?
This way.
And then, left?
This way, left.
And it's like right in front of us.
Oh, right here.
Oh.
Oh, is this always here?
Yeah.
Um, yeah.
You just never see this elevator?
Wait, did I?
Oh, it's coming.
Yeah, yeah, it's just a little slow.
Don't let that guy in.
He's creepy.
Okay, close it.
We don't.
I got the roof.
That could be Ray's right now.
You don't know that.
Right?
Ray?
Yeah.
He's been with us the whole time.
Yeah, he's been with us.
That's a little scary though.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Oh.
It's the cat!
Oh, the cat!
The cat's here.
Can we talk to him?
Fly away with the moon is our objective.
Did we talk to the cat?
Get in!
Oh, the wife?
Oh.
Yeah, I see our Santa over there.
She's coming home with me!
You're gonna pick us up and spin us and throw us into the moon.
I hope so, actually.
Hello, giant woman.
All right, mince.
Oh, okay.
Your wife time.
She says, it seems like this is the end.
The moon is already waiting for you.
And yet, you managed to pull it off.
That's it.
We're going home.
Fly away now!
Fly away!
Will you come fly with me?
I wish I could, but I have to stay behind.
I don't have a fancy space suit like yours, so I can't brave the great unknown.
She's a robot.
She's still talking?
My girl!
Goodbye, forever.
Yeah.
She doesn't want to come to the space with us.
You're not gonna come to space with us?
Go on, sweetie!
No!
There's a bridge here!
Mint, what's your final words to your wife?
Careful, careful!
I love you in latex.
It's time to say goodbye to this place and move on.
I'm not ready.
No!
Okay, that's the last thing she says.
It's time, guys.
Are we all ready?
Yeah!
Let's go!
We're doing it!
Don't ever forget you, space lady!
Thank you for making her the happiest mint around.
I'll never forget the bachelor party.
Wait, are we actually gonna see space now?
That'd be crazy.
I mean, that's why we put on the space suit.
Yeah, there we go.
Are you guys ready?
It looks even a little small for all of us.
Set out on a journey.
I know, right?
We're gonna live inside of it.
We all have to be nearby.
Oh?
Oh my god.
We're each having our own little experience.
We're flying away now!
Our people need me!
Wee!
Goodbye, mince wife!
Goodbye!
Wee!
The mission is complete!
Thanks, manager!
We did it!
We finally got the moon!
Oh my god!
It's so beautiful!
We actually beat the game!
I also understood nothing.
I, I...
That was a wild game.
That game was fucking wild.
Hello?
Oh!
Hello!
We're back?
How do we...
Wait, why are we back?
What?
I thought we flew...
New game plans!
I thought we all flew away!
We're back!
What happened?
Where is...
The creatures are still here even.
Wait, like...
Did we not...
We beat the game though!
Yeah, we beat it.
We beat it!
Yeah!
Like, it was...
We got kicked off the moon?
The cat!
Wait!
Oh!
The cat!
Hello?
Oh, scary!
Aw, he's happy!
Aw, he's not...
He's not evil anymore!
Is the moon up there?
Wait, maybe...
Maybe this was for like...
Uh...
The TV head guy.
If you put the orange on his head when the moon is already out.
Then he...
Like, lives on the moon with us.
But since we did it early...
He just floated off into...
Oh!
He's just...
Space!
We did the order of operations a little wrong.
Yeah...
Wait, I thought the creatures were supposed to be gone though.
I still see them walking around.
Oh wait, there's two TV heads here we could talk to.
Oh!
Oh yeah!
Strange.
You left with the moon, didn't you?
Oh, they're acknowledging it.
Yeah, we thought so!
Yeah, we all floated away!
Yeah!
Did we forget to finish something?
Oh, I guess it's New Game Plus and we didn't do...
No moon here anymore!
Aww!
That was fun guys!
I had a fun time!
Yeah!
I told you the yellow women had a plan!
Uh huh!
Yeah, mhm, mhm, mhm.
That was faster than I thought it would be!
Yeah, I thought so, yeah!
Even if this guy on YouTube only one hour...
Yeah, yeah!
He had all the information, okay!
Okay, yeah, yeah!
We...
We figured it out as we went along!
See, never dealt our plan!
Never!
It was good, it was good!
Yeah, yeah!
Yeah!
Yeah, I had a fun time!
With all of you guys today!
Yeah, and also like...
Yeah!
When we first started the game...
I did not ex...
I...
Honestly, I don't know what we just did.
Like, I...
I'm a little confused on the plot of the story.
Yeah, me too!
What we did is played more than two hours, so we can never return the game.
No, it was cool, though.
It was cool.
Maybe they'll add more to it.
Maybe they'll add a second moon.
You know what I mean?
Oh no!
DLC.
The moon DLC.
Some of those bosses, I never want to see again.
I think I'm good.
Yeah.
Yeah, the one that like...
Just like, punts us to the ground.
That...
I know, that guy is horrible.
Like, look, he always comes out of nowhere, too.
Like, we don't even know when he shows up.
I wish we could see the...
Like, a death count of who died the moon.
Oh, I'm pretty sure someone in our chat can...
I know, right?
Like, do a compilation of that.
Like, who died the moon.
It has time, yeah.
Me and Nimi are in sync.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh!
Yeah, you guys are!
We should line up.
We should like, line up on the edge of the building and do like a...
Oh!
A little...
A synced dance.
That's so true!
But which dance?
A Macarena?
Which number?
Let's do like...
I'll stand right here, fine.
Wait, which number?
Which number?
Which way do we face?
Do we face...
Maybe in a line, like, yeah.
Like that?
Okay.
Someone has to tell us the number to do.
Yeah.
Wait, which way?
Which way do we look...
Yeah, yeah.
He's looking.
Alright, alright, alright.
How about...
Whatever.
What dance.
Is it dance 2?
No, that's the chicken dance.
Okay, okay.
We'll do a countdown.
Are you guys ready?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It stands two.
Yeah, are you ready?
Three.
Wait, how do I... wait, hold on.
Oh, I gotta stop.
Okay.
Alright.
I'll do it on one, okay?
Okay.
Oh, you just have to move a little bit.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
We're just... none of us.
Howard, none of us.
We're trying.
Alright, switch to dance.
Eight.
One.
Three, two, one.
Dancing!
We're at sync!
Okay, um... maybe not me, though.
No, it kind of works.
It's like a delay.
It's like, I'm first.
Yeah.
That's true.
You guys saw how everybody calls this green and yellow woman, right?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Very creative.
Very, very creative.
This is good.
GG's, guys.
What a journey.
I think this was a mission success for us.
Yeah.
I'm dead.
I love these stupid horror games, so I'm always down.
Me too!
The Kuso game?
I love it.
Me too.
Especially, like, voice proximity.
Ready?
Yes!
Yeah!
Come on.
I love voice.
Okay, can we do flip?
All right.
Do the countdown.
One, three, two, one.
We just did it!
Wait, what is F?
What?
What's F?
Oh, salute.
Oh!
It's whenever someone dies.
Oh, we should have done that!
I don't even see it!
Me too!
Every time someone dies, we could have all been around their body and...
That flip was awesome!
That was a...
It was!
That was a pretty cool flip.
Someone should make a montage of just that flip.
With different perspectives.
You know?
GG's, guys.
I had a great time with all of you.
With my green and yellow women.
Yeah!
GG's!
Until...
Well, I hope we get to play something again in the future.
Yeah!
Yeah, GG's, guys.
I guess we'll talk to our chat now.
Okay!
All right, bye-bye, guys!
Thanks for joining me on this channel!
Bye-bye!
F.
It was an honor.
It was an honor, everyone.
F.
Hi!
Bye-bye!
If I leave, the entire server closes.
So I'll do that.
Wait, I want to see if I can die by this thing.
Oh, okay.
I guess we could F her.
Help me!
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay, she's dead.
Give an F for her.
Goodbye.
Oh, wait.
That was fun!
I had a great time with, uh, Mint, uh, Doobie, and Nimi.
All right, let me swap over to...
It's summer, right?
Yeah, summertime.
I got it.
Oh, I can...
Let me...
Okay, we flew back...
Back on Earth now.
I had a great time with the three girls.
It was fun.
I had a fun time.
But yeah, Doobie and I, we, like, researched a little bit before the stream.
Um, just cause, like, we wanted to make sure we can complete it today.
Uh, but we didn't spoil ourselves.
We just wanted to know, like, where to...
What to do next.
Just cause we were so trapped in that one area.
So, like, it was just for, like, the yellow...
Like, cause, like, I was so confused about the yellow car.
And then she was confused about that other area.
I know.
We're heroes, guys.
We've landed back on planet Earth.
We're heroes.
Uh...
Where's our parade?
Um...
But, like, after that, we didn't, like, really know what to do after that.
But I'm glad we were able to complete the game.
You know?
Um, complete the game today.
Cause, you know, it was, uh...
It was a lot of...
It was a...
You know?
There were some tasks there.
That was...
Super complicated and everything.
Um...
And...
And we had to split up, gang.
Yeah.
Um...
But it was really fun.
I had a great time.
Uh...
I had a great time with all of them.
And I'm happy that we did this...
We...
We did a collab together.
Uh...
Okay, collab is over.
Put my Fugi back on.
Uh...
Seijin, thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
I have to convince our lack of map knowledge actually became the good part.
Since this brought us on amazing adventure.
Thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, like...
That was...
The fact that none of us realized that we could have used the map this entire time.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe we...
We actually made it so much harder for ourselves.
Um...
Uh...
No, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How Nimi's stats affect the viability of...
of green and yellow.
We're still green and yellow.
And we're still women.
Um...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Pyro, thank you for the super chat.
Hi, Doki.
I turned 22 yesterday.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course you can.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Pyro.
Nyaaaah!
Happy birthday!
Alright, let me look at the super chat reading.
Oh yeah, for those who are wondering, for dad update, he is just resting right now.
He's on a strict two weeks, four week rest at the moment.
So, I just wish him good luck on his recovery.
Alright, where was I?
On my super chat.
Lacon, Mehdi, Nepers, Morph Balls, Byte, Alan, Matt, Chi, Ryu, Forward.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Alan, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Ah, Seijen, thank you for the super stickers, thank you, thank you.
Kenshin, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I will follow Doki into death.
If Doki were an anvil, call me crazy, but I'll be fine with her falling on me.
What else is there?
Uh, Alan, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yes, Doki, keep going.
You're gonna finish the g- ah.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha I got to be in your stream live,
finally.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
I think my favorite part during that stream was when... was when Doobie was like, Hey, guys, you're going the wrong.
And then she died.
He's in front of me.
That was so good.
I was just like, Oh, my God.
They killed Doobie.
I was like, Oh, my God.
Doobie.
Like, he came out of nowhere.
I thought of us.
I was like, Oh, where was he?
He killed the kid, the team.
Like, you bastards.
It was just like, every time.
I swear, like, it always happens to her, too.
Because, like, that happened to her, like, um, I think, like, like, at least four times within the two parts that we played.
It was crazy that, uh, that that happened so many times.
Um, let's see.
Uh, best part of the stream was boobs.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, literally, the fact that only two people was typing the right number, but it was so hard to...
Because it was such a fucking long password.
So, like, every time I could see it, I only saw the first three digits.
And then the boobs fan, like, like, bumped it off of my chat.
So, I couldn't... I had to, like, wait until the guy reposted the password.
That was the point of boobs.
I was like, guys, please, I can't fucking see.
It can't be boobs.
Um, I couldn't stop.
Yeah, I forgot.
I know.
I was like, why didn't I just tab out and stop the squirrel?
I was just so locked in.
I was so fucking locked in.
You don't understand.
Oh, thank you, super chat.
Thank you.
I just came back from shopping and stuff.
Did you guys have a grand gay time?
Audio, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Every moment felt like the phrase, what could go wrong?
Surely it can't get worse, right?
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yellow women.
Why?
Yeah, thank you, guys.
I had a fun time with Nini Doobie and Mint.
I hope they had a fun time with me, too.
I hope they all had a good time with this game.
It's always nice to play, like, you know, these, like...
I guess, are they friend slop?
I feel like everything... every, like, collab game is now categorized as friend slop.
Like, what makes it a friend slop and what doesn't make it a friend slop?
Like, even, like, good games.
Like, good collab games, people call it a friend slop.
Like...
Yeah, I'm just like...
What doesn't make it a friend slop these days?
Like, I'm so confused.
I feel like people are overusing that word now.
Yeah, it lost its meaning.
Smug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I always wished for a collab between Nini and you.
So the streams made me so happy.
Can't wait for another friend slop game with this group.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's been fun doing collabs again.
I know, like, we have been on a...
We haven't really done much collabs and branching out of the group for a while.
Um, I think, like, for a few months, uh, a few months ago.
Uh, but yeah, I'm slowly...
My streak of collabing with people and meeting new people has continued.
Um, uh, next week...
What is my schedule like for next week, actually?
I actually don't know.
Um...
Oh, I haven't put anything down...
Oh, wait, uh...
Next week, uh...
We have, uh...
It's August...
Okay, it's August 1.
Okay, so next week, we're...
We got...
There's, like, I think, like, two sponsors next week.
Yeah, there's two sponsors next week.
For those who don't know, we have a Vita Ramen sponsor.
Um, uh, we're...
We're...
We're releasing a bunch of videos to celebrate the sponsor.
For those who don't know what Vita Ramen is, usually they do a lot of knife collabs.
I can't really spoil exactly what the products are.
But, you know, they've done quite a couple of knives, uh, for other VTubers.
And there's other stuff, too.
Hmm...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha...
There may or may not be other stuff, too.
Hmm...
Ha ha ha ha ha...
So...
Um...
There's that.
And then we also have another sponsor that I can't name yet.
Because I haven't signed the contract yet.
So, um...
Um...
That will be, uh, announced soon-ish.
It's basically, uh...
We've done the sponsor before, too, so...
Hmm...
Ha ha ha ha ha...
Ha ha ha ha...
Um...
That's all I can say.
Ha ha ha ha...
Uh...
Oh, I think we have three sponsors.
Actually, oh my god.
I have the next week.
Um...
Money!
Ha ha ha ha...
Okay, guys.
Okay, but like...
I hate...
Guys, I...
I need to rebuild my funding.
Ha ha ha ha...
Um...
I had a great time.
Yay!
So I can do more stuff.
So I can...
Uh...
Invest more in my channel!
Let's go!
Let's, uh, go!
Doki Bird!
Yippee!
Um...
Did you guys see that?
Oh my gosh.
Did you guys see...
Okay.
I want to talk to you guys a little bit more before I go.
Ha ha ha...
Uh...
So even though I finished all my Super Chats, I still want to hang out with you guys.
But...
Did you guys see the...
The new Overwatch update?
But like only...
In the Chinese server.
Where they...
You know how like on Valentine's Day, they released a...
Uh...
They released a...
Visual novel.
Um...
They did that again.
But it's only exclusive to the Chinese servers.
And you can actually like...
You're like actually going on a date with the Overwatch characters.
Like...
And like...
It's an actual like...
You're trying to...
Um...
Boost your like...
Love rate.
Yeah, yeah.
With the...
Uh...
With the other like...
Overwatch characters and stuff.
Yeah, you can...
You can actually date them.
Yeah.
Ha ha ha ha...
It was a visual...
Yeah, it is...
It was crazy.
And it has like unique...
There's like unique skins.
And...
Cause like...
You remember the Valentine's Day one?
It was like...
It was an April Fool's type thing.
Um...
But for this one, they actually went all out.
But I think like there was a trailer and everything.
Uh...
So...
Wait, I'll show...
I'll link it to you guys.
I like bookmarked it.
But you can date MAGA.
Ha ha ha ha...
I was like, oh my god.
Like...
What?
I can't believe it's like only in...
In China servers too.
I thought they would like...
Release it to...
Worldwide.
Um...
And everything.
So I thought it was super interesting.
Uh...
I saw like a video...
A video trailer of it, but...
Um...
I saw a video trailer of it, but I didn't like...
Bookmarked it.
Uh...
Pun!
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi Doki!
It's my birthday!
So glad to celebrate the dragons!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Pun Gun!
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Brittany, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank.
Yeah.
Um...
What else did I want to talk about?
Oh, yes.
I'll announce what tomorrow's stream is.
Okay, so there's two announcements.
Um...
But I'll do the first announcement right now.
Because...
Um, you guys might... I'll be uploading the waiting room anyway later tonight.
Or in the morning, depends on when I'm getting my thumbnail sent over.
Um, but, um, for tomorrow, um, we are the special stream for tomorrow.
It is a public stream.
So, the thing about it is that we're finally relaunching the Doki SMP Minecraft server for the Dragoons.
So, members, right now, members, if you check your, um, community post, um, if you check the community post right now, um, there is details on how to join the server.
So, um, the thing about the server is that, uh, I have to stream once a month on it, um, every month.
At least one time every month.
And, um, and it will have, it has to be, it will be a public stream.
So, every time I play on the server, it will be a public stream.
So, we fixed a lot of issues that was going on with 1.0 Doki SMP.
And the reason why it took so long to relaunch it is that we had to do a full overhaul on a lot of the stuff.
And re-update the plugins and everything for it for the newest Minecraft update.
So, if you're having issues connecting your Discord to YouTube...
My suggestion is to re-link your account and make sure it's the correct YouTube account.
So, just re-link it or log out and log back in.
Apparently, it's like a common problem if you need to re-link it and stuff.
You still need to... Technically, yes.
I still need to do Marvel Rival...
I haven't done the Marvel Rival stream quota the last two months because I've been very, very busy.
I was like apologizing because devs are really nice to me.
Um, the devs actually were like...
They actually like contacted me asking me if like...
Um, they were like...
Do you wanna...
Do you wanna go to LAN?
Like, that's in China?
That's in two weeks?
Like, they would...
They wanted to pay for like my flight and uh...
My hotels and everything.
And I was so sweet of them.
I was like...
Oh my god.
What?
Hahaha.
Yeah.
But like...
Um...
Sadly...
I couldn't really do the things they wanted me to do.
Uh...
Um...
There...
Yeah.
I was like...
You know, they wanted to...
Invite me to the LAN.
That like...
The Marvel Rivals.
The first Marvel Rivals LAN.
And everything.
But like...
They...
They want...
Cause um...
They wanted to like...
Do some events and stuff.
Um...
But then I was like...
Oh, I...
I'm a VTuber.
Haha.
You know?
I was like...
Oh, I can't really do all those things.
But then I...
Gave them like...
Suggestions.
And stuff.
And I was like...
Oh...
Um...
You know, like...
In Japan.
They've done like...
VTuber LAN events.
Where they put like a cardboard...
Like a...
Cardboard cutout.
Or they use like screens and stuff.
Pretending they're there.
And then the...
Uh...
The VTuber would like...
Play behind the scenes and stuff.
So they're like...
They're like...
Oh, we'll look into that.
We really want you to...
We really want you to participate.
Um...
You know?
We're like...
We really want you to participate in the future LANs and stuff.
So...
Um...
I sent them links to the videos of that too.
Like the videos of...
Um...
Like the Valorant LAN...
The Valorant LAN thing.
Where like...
They put a cardboard cutout.
Of...
Like people.
And like also the street fighters.
And stuff like that.
That they did in Japan.
And they said they're looking into that for the future LANs that they're doing.
And I thought that was so sweet.
You know, they're really nice to me and everything.
So yeah, I really appreciate that.
But I love working with my rival devs because they're really, really nice to me.
And Apex devs have also been super nice to me too.
Well, they've always been super nice to me.
And then you guys are like, Toki, why are you mentioning the Apex devs?
All of a sudden, it's been a while since you played Apex.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just get Saikuno on stage, but you play Rainbow.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But yeah, I really appreciate it.
Like I said in the last stream...
Anyways, the second last stream...
Oh wait, Melanie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They're fine with it because they know you're already hooked on Marvel Rivals.
You'll be back.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But I really appreciate all these companies working with me and everything.
Like I said, when I came back, a lot of these companies...
Um, I know some of us were confused about like, oh, what does she mean by like, uh, professionally?
I meant like more so like, you know, the VTuber... in the VTuber community, it is like very...
Um, when I said like, oh, you know, like I was like a bit radioactive within the...
Professionally within the VTuber company.
So it was really nice, uh, um, that, uh, you know, all these companies like outside of the VTuber company wanted to work with me on all these things.
Because like, you know, you assume that you have to be corporate to like get these opportunities and stuff.
So it's, I felt really honored and like, you know, very lucky, um, that, you know, despite everything, um, you know, I was able to, um, get these opportunities and, um, be able to do all these things, uh, for you guys and with you guys.
And I really appreciate, uh, I really appreciate all my draggoons for supporting me throughout, um, the years too.
Um, and, um, and, um, um, it really does mean a lot because, you know, I couldn't do all of this without your support and your belief in me and everything.
Like, I'm very lucky.
I'm a very lucky, uh, very lucky for how it turned out in the end because it could have turned out very differently.
And I'm very lucky to have you guys as, uh, as my community.
And I'm very happy and I'm really happy for all the companies that believed in me.
And especially as an individual, you know, like taking a risk on an individual is, is, is like a lot too.
So, um, so, especially when, you know, um, I had to learn a lot.
Like I said, I messed up a lot, you know, like the Doki SMP 1.0.
I did not realize how much work that was at first.
Like, like, I, I did not realize how much work it was and like how much like it, it like time I had to like actually put on it.
Because we were like trying to whitelist people by hand and it was so, it was a very bad decision.
And I rushed it.
I did rush it.
I, cause I really wanted some fun things for you guys.
And I was like, I want to do so many things.
And I did, I messed up on that and I learned, I learned from my mistakes.
And that's why we, we took, when we like went to re redo everything, um, we took more time in, um, um, in trying to make sure that the server is, you know, the things I want to do and stuff is actually done before we launch it.
And like, you know, have stuff more automatic and everything and look into more like, look more, uh, what's it called quality of life changes and stuff like that.
So, uh, I'm glad that, um, I was able to, you know, learn from a lot of my mistakes and every day, every week, every day, I get better at my job.
If you think about it that way.
Every day we just, we get a little bit better at our job.
And I'm still learning.
I'm, I know it's like, I've been streaming for a while, but like, handling, I, I, when I took my career seriously, I was in a corporate, like area, like I was in a corporate environment.
And so like, that was so different from doing it in an indie environment.
And it made me realize just like, you know, a lot of things, all of like the checks and, what's it called?
The checks and balances and like making sure like everything is going the right way.
Um, and I had to do that on my own with my staff too.
But you know, maybe some of my staff is not, uh, uh, me and my staff, like have to figure that out together, um, and had a lot more responsibility.
And as the final check and everything too.
There's so much to learn.
Yeah.
Um, you know, I had to learn a lot of that from the ground up and everything.
So, uh, there's a lot of growth for me too.
Um, and I hope I, I grew a lot as a person.
Um, and I feel like I did.
I feel like I grew a lot as a person in terms of how to handle things.
Um, I mean, I'm still human.
So, I'm still human.
So, I still make mistakes and stuff.
Like, I do.
I, I am a very emotional person.
Um, in general.
But I've learned to like delegate things.
If I do get too emotional, I've learned to like delegate stuff.
And, um, and, you know, um, pass it on to others to work on things.
If I want to work on something else and focus my energy on something else, I delegate it to others.
Like this, the Doki SMP.
Um, I delegate it to a staff member, um, for it.
For it, um, for it when I realized, like, I can't handle this by myself.
And, um, um, and I'm really proud of how much they've worked on this.
And, uh, they worked on it.
And, you know, it looks really good.
And I can't wait to, I can't wait to, uh, to get on the server.
Uh, with all of you guys.
And, you know, re-experience the Doki SMP again.
Rebuild.
We will rebuild it.
It will be better than 1.0.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Uh, uh, Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No one ever gets it correct on the first try.
What's the support is that you never get out.
And you learn from yesterday's mistakes to make tomorrow a better place.
Thank you.
Thank you for the superchat.
I really appreciate it.
You just naturally shine so bright that companies and people can't help but be drawn to you.
Keep moving for it and we'll keep following.
Saying lots of love.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Yeah, like... um... I remember like... uh... when... um... I think... I'm gonna like word- word this in my head before I say it... but I remember when, you know...
A lot of people behind the scenes helping me when I first got fired and everything.
It was a lot.
But I really appreciate all the love and support, especially behind the scenes from people messaging me and everything.
And I really appreciate that.
And I grew a lot as a person too.
So, it meant a lot.
Okay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, SMP, what is this?
It's a Minecraft server for members!
If you're a member, look into the community post.
Look into the community post and you can join...
You can get whitelisted before the server comes up.
The server won't be live until tomorrow when I stream, by the way.
For those who are wondering, it won't...
You can get whitelisted in advance.
And also, if there's any support you need before the server goes up.
Powerball, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, delegating work.
Thank you, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's in the members.
It's in the members community.
If you're a member, you'll see it.
Yeah.
You'll see it and everything.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Um...
But yeah.
I really, really appreciate it all.
Guys, thank you all for the support.
I feel really mushy because...
You know, after all the events...
The last week that's been happening...
I just feel really mushy right now.
Hahaha!
Rodrigo, thank you for the five gift of the shows!
Thank you, thank you!
Um...
Just like I said, I couldn't be here without all of you guys.
And...
Um...
It was definitely very overwhelming.
It was very overwhelming when I had to do all of this.
Uh...
Like...
You know, when my...
The rug was pulled out from under me.
And I had to like...
Figure out how to do all of this myself.
Uh...
With a small group of people.
Um...
And like I said, we all had to learn.
We all had...
It was just trial and error and everything.
Um...
You know, I never had to run my own...
I mean, technically it's...
It's a company because...
But my...
The company is like based off of me.
Like...
Like my own brand.
It's not really a company company.
But like...
You know...
Um...
It is a business.
And my...
My company is just about me.
But I had so much to learn.
And...
Um...
I'm really thankful for how things turned out in the end.
Like...
You know...
I don't really want to waste this opportunity.
I don't want to squander it.
There were so many eyes on me at that time.
And it was definitely very overwhelming.
Um...
There were times where I did wish...
That...
Um...
I had...
Someone...
Offer me...
Like...
Corporate assistance.
Because...
I was very overwhelmed.
It was so much.
There were so many offers and stuff.
But it wasn't like...
You know...
It was outside the VTuber community.
So like...
There were so many offers for help.
Uh...
For like...
You know...
Sponsors and like...
Merch.
Well...
And stuff like that.
Um...
But it's like...
Outside of the VTuber community.
And like...
It's very hard.
Cause I- I don't know.
Cuz the thing is...
When there's help...
Outside of the VTuber community.
It's very hard to see like...
Which...
one to trust.
Because I didn't know...
I didn't have much knowledge about a lot of things like the marketing agencies.
I had so many offers from different marketing agencies, but I didn't know which one to trust or which one to sign and stuff like that.
Because a lot of these marketing agencies wanted to sign me, but that's not like a VTuber company, you know?
Or like a lot of talent agencies and stuff.
But I didn't know which one to sign and I didn't know who to trust because I already got out and I was like, I don't know.
It was so overwhelming.
That's why I never signed with a talent agency.
I never signed with a talent agency.
I never signed with a marketing agency.
They approached me.
If they have something, they approach me.
I'm not fully signed on to anything.
Because like, I don't know if you guys know this, but having an agent is like... I don't have like... I don't actually have an agent agent.
If an agent wants... some agents... I'm like, oh, what's the word called?
I have a manager and I have staff, but I don't have an agent agent.
I have several agents that come to me if there's a project that they have in mind that fits my criteria.
And they come to me and they just take a percentage off and that's fine.
Or the sponsors themselves reach out to me, like specifically reach out to me to like, I guess like cut the middleman out or something.
They just don't want a middleman involved.
So they're just like, oh, we'll just reach out to you specifically.
Yeah, I'm just like a freelance stuff.
So I don't really have like an actual agent that like...
But I have various agents that...
I have various agents that basically like bring me up if there's something that, you know, matches the sponsor or matches the collab or something like that.
Which works!
It works for me.
That's why you don't see me sign for any...
Maybe in the future, I would.
Maybe in the future, I would like, you know, take an offer or something like that.
But yeah, no, it was very overwhelming starting out.
But I'm happy with where we are now.
It was a lot of work to get here.
It was so tiring.
I've had like breakdowns in the past being like, I wish I was in a company right now with corporate assistance.
Because like, you know, like it was so much.
It was a lot of work.
And when you had so much work by yourself.
But even with a team, even with a team, I was like, I had like breakdowns being like, oh my gosh, this is...
Because it was like, you know, I wasn't used to that much workload in the past.
And it was a lot to learn.
And I made so many mistakes to getting to where I am today.
Um, yeah, it was like, like, I'm happy with where I am at now.
But it took a long journey to get there.
Learning from everything.
Um, and, um, like with the, even with, you know, I had so much freedom.
But I had to still make the right decision with all that freedom.
Um, yeah.
Um, uh, yeah, so I even like at one point, um, it's actually really funny.
At one point, um, I won't say like what, which orgs, but like, I asked like several esport orgs if they were willing to, you know, like, like just propose an idea.
Being like, how you guys, do you guys want to sign like, you know, a VTuber?
Like, you know, you sign less streamers, but like, how about VTubers?
But I even like brought that up to esport orgs too, because I was like, hey.
Uh, hahaha.
Yeah.
Like, it even got to like that point, cause I was just, like the transition period was so overwhelming.
It was, it was just, uh, it was so much work.
But in the end, I'm happy with where, like, like, obviously you don't see me on an esport org.
You know, see me in an esport org.
Um, cause obviously it didn't work out in the end, like during like negotiations and stuff.
Um, and honestly, like, I'm, like I said, um, I'm happy with where I'm at.
I don't know what I was saying.
I'm glad the negotiations in the end didn't work out.
Um, um, cause you know, we had two, we had like different expectations basically of each other.
We had different expectations for each other.
So like, um, um, so it's not like, you know, oh, like I didn't like what they wanted.
Like I didn't like the contracts or no, it was, we just had different expectations of what we wanted to do.
So like, obviously, you know, it didn't work out in the end.
Um, but I don't want to say like, oh, you know, like, oh, uh, but you know, what could have been.
It's more so of like, what could have been.
But, and in the end, I'm, I'm happy with where I'm at.
My man, I don't know if my manager is awake, but he's gonna be like, bullshit, you cried so much.
But look, in retrospective, I'm reflecting.
I'm reflecting right now.
I'm, in the past, in the, in the past, you know, I would cry about it.
He'd be like, come on, it's so much work.
I'm so tired.
And you'd be like, oh, why don't you like, you know, um, maybe, you know, we could ask this company or something.
And I'd be like, oh, no, no, I don't know.
Oh, I don't know.
It feels, oh, I feel like, cause like at one point, cause my manager would be like, oh, how about you ask.
You know, well, maybe you can ask this company, like if they want to take you in.
And then, you know, and I was like, oh, I feel so pathetic.
I'd be like, oh, I feel so pathetic.
Like, I think about it.
I'll wait tomorrow.
I'll wait tomorrow and see it.
Cause I'll be like, no, I feel pathetic.
They didn't even offer me anything.
They didn't even approach me.
I feel, I'll think about it.
Like, I don't, what if they say no?
I was like, I was like, what if they say no?
Then I'll feel worse.
Um, but in the end, I'm glad it all worked out in the end.
I'm glad it all.
I mean, like reflecting it.
And yeah, I was spiraling it.
That fear of rejection.
Yeah.
I know you guys are like, yo, the worst they can say is no.
But I was, I was very, I was in a sensitive spot there.
I couldn't even take a no at that point.
I was like, I was like, you guys don't understand.
I couldn't take a no guys.
I was just like, I couldn't, I couldn't take it around that time.
But now we have a team.
Now we've built a team that I'm very confident around.
And, um, they, they do a lot.
Like our team is getting bigger and bigger, but like in a way where I can afford it.
That's what I mean.
Um, in a way that I can afford the bigger, I can afford the team.
Um, oh, we're the back.
Oh, was the BGM doubled?
I'm so sorry.
That must've been.
So, I'm sorry.
That must've been like, really, really hard to listen to.
Oh man, I didn't even realize.
Um, um, so, uh, um, oh, now you can't unhear it anywhere.
Oh, that's good.
Now people won't watch the end.
No one can know how vulnerable I was at the end of super chat reading.
That's right.
Hahaha!
Um, um, and our team is getting bigger and our team is getting more experience too.
Um, more experience on how to handle all the stuff that's going on.
And yeah, it's been quite a journey everyone.
It really has been.
And I hope everyone in the VTuber community lands on their feet.
I know a lot of people might not be as lucky as I was, and a lot of people have their own struggles and their own journey to go on.
I hope in the end everyone finds their path, like how I found my path in the end.
Like I thought, I thought I had to be, I thought in the past I had to be corporate to be successful.
But like, to do the things I want, well not just successful, but to do the things I want to do.
Like I have such, I have so many ideas and so much ambition and a lot of goals I want to do.
And it's, you know, doing it by myself with my team, it was so much work.
So, um, we're like getting there, you know, we're get, we're getting there.
No, we're getting there.
Um, and yeah, we accomplished a lot.
And I hope I continue to grow as a person and continue to, um, you know, continue to do the things I want to be able to do.
So, and then I hit a million subscribers and I peace out and disappear.
I'm joking!
Please, please, please, don't unsubscribe.
Please, millions, I'll still be here.
I'll still be here after a million subscribers.
I, I still be here.
I swear, please, don't unsubscribe.
I was joking.
The second one is J.aky J.k.
slash J.K...
I actually have something special planned in a million- not leaving.
I have a special...
a special stream slash announcement slash like, thing.
Out of a million subscribers, guys.
So you guys, please, you guys wanna see the special announcement, right?
I actually have something very special planned out of a million subscribers.
I swear it is not a graduation.
I swear to God.
Um...
But yeah.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you, bro.
Sorry, I got really mushy and emotional there.
The last, like, three days has been a lot.
Like, obviously, like, it's been more for a lot of people that were actually affected.
Um, but it got me, like, super... it got me in a super reflective mood.
Um, just looking back at my, like, looking back at, like, you know, the history of my career.
And I got... I got, like, super reflective and... about it and everything.
And I've been thinking a lot about it, too.
Um, um, so I got super mushy there today.
You know, there was, like, I even, like, typed up a lot of stuff that was in my head while I was, like, um...
That was all going on.
And in the end, even though, like, I never got really got any offers after I got fired, I'm sort of glad I didn't.
I... I was at a very vulnerable place back then.
Like, I feel like if I did get one, I would have taken it.
Um, because of how vulnerable I was.
Um, and, like, I'm glad I didn't get poached because I was able to build all of this up and, like, have all of these connections now.
Um, and everything.
So, um, I didn't mean, like, you know, any offer, you know?
I wouldn't just say any offer.
But, you know, back then, you know, when, you know, back then, like, in hindsight, obviously, like, you know...
Bishoujo was a company that everyone thought was too good to be true.
And it was too good to be true.
Yeah.
Um, and obviously, like...
I had...
I read some comments of people being, like, oh, maybe they were scared.
Because, you know, I went through a lot, too, back then.
And, um...
And I guess, like, maybe they thought that I would have noticed something was wrong.
A lot earlier.
Because I'd be like, wait a minute.
I played these games before.
And I was like, oh, wait, yeah, that makes sense.
That actually...
I was like, wait a minute.
Wait, yeah, that...
That...
That would...
That actually made sense.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'd be like, wait a minute.
I played these games before.
Because I am a very outspoken person.
Like, I basically fight for what's right in the past and current.
Like, if I think something's not right, I do butt heads.
And, like, because I have done that.
And I think something's not right.
And, like, I remember I would fight for a lot of permit perms and stuff back then.
And found, like, ways to get perms.
I remember, like, there was a game that we all wanted to play.
And I would literally... I literally went on a Discord server.
Like, the devs... Like, the game devs Discord server to get us, like, perms and stuff.
Because I was, like... I would get on an anonymous account and be like, hey, guys.
I was wondering, are you guys allowed over... Like, are you guys allowed people to stream it?
Some countries don't have good copyright laws.
They don't have... What was it called?
Fair use laws.
And so, I just wanted to know.
Yeah.
And I would, like, actually look... Yeah.
Stuff like that.
And they're like, oh, wow.
Really?
Well, yeah.
You got people overseas can stream our game.
Asking for a friend, by the way.
I'm just asking for a friend.
My friend's a streamer and she wanted to know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope you realize how much all of us dragoons appreciate and love you.
You're our light in the dark.
Kind of the light.
I'm glad that out of all of you YouTubers out there, you can be my Kamioshi.
Love you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I'm happy to be your Kamioshi.
For as long as you'll have me.
Swizznate, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome.
Rodrigo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I know that feeling.
I'm definitely emotional this week.
So glad you're here with us.
It was a struggle, but you made it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Next to you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Everything worked out for the best.
I was thinking about how we're living in the best timeline right now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Forward.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Looking forward to seeing everything you have in store for us.
This journey with you and the dragoons have been a blast to be part of.
You've grown so much and I always keep saying this.
I'm so freaking proud of you, Doki.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm proud of you guys too!
We grew a lot as a community together, so I'm really proud of all of us.
Like, I couldn't be able to do all of this without you guys too.
Mustard, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Manny, thank you for the super chat.
Year by year, I'm more proud to have supported you all this time.
Thank you!
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, you're getting me out of here.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Next to you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You'll be back.
You love money too much.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm just proud of our journey together, Dragoon.
Like I said, I couldn't be here without all of your support and everything.
Can't do the things I do without you guys.
Billy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
I used to watch you with another member account, but I just want to say thank you here.
Thank you.
Thank you, Billy.
And also, you're the one that clips me, right?
And translates me in Chinese.
So thank you.
I love people who clip me around the world to translate my stuff for people, for my overseas fans and everything.
I really appreciate it.
I really appreciate all my community for, you know, spreading the word of Doki.
Doki.
Rice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for kindly sharing what it was like.
We're happy you made it here.
Thank you.
Rice, Ivan, thank you for the super chat.
All things can do it.
You've come out of the fire stronger than ever.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doom, thank you for the super chat.
Alright, guys.
One more super chat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
With how Doki is talking, maybe she is graduating.
No, I swear to God, it's not.
The special announcement is not a graduate.
I'm not leaving at a million.
It was just JK slash JK.
It's actually a million and a one.
JK slash... Slash JK, guys.
Slash JK.
Yeah.
In the end, alright, my final thoughts.
In the end, I hope everyone supports and keep doing what they love in the VTuber community.
Support everyone in the VTuber community.
Support... I like the phrasing.
They're like, support the talents.
Talents is really the most important part.
Uh, of it.
Um, yeah.
Believe in, like, um, believe in their dreams and everything.
And, um, I hope everyone finds the path that they're meant to find in the end.
Um, and yeah.
It's been quite a week for the VTuber community, really.
It's been a fucking crazy week and everything.
Um, and I hope, um...
I hope everyone has the resolution that they wanted in the end.
Um...
But, yeah.
I'm gonna end it there.
I'll read one last Super Chat, which is from Tia.
In the Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for working hard despite it being hard.
You inspire us.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
And if it's, like, super overwhelming, guys.
If it's all too overwhelming with everything that, you know, all the news that's come out, just...
Take a break.
Um, for a little bit.
Because I'll still be here.
I'll still be here for you guys.
So, if you need a rest, if you guys need to, you know, get offline a little bit and rest and, you know, go outside.
I know outside just feels very dangerous, but...
But if it helps your mental...
You know, I'll be here.
I'll be here for you guys.
You can always return here.
I'll still be doing the same old shit.
I'll still be doing the same old thing here.
Um, I might be... I might be on the moon, but I'm still here.
Hey, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye.